Okay.
Four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're alive.
So what am I not supposed to say?
Huh?
Oh,
a cunt.
Oh yeah,
that's all right.
That's the title.
The title of the show that we've,
we've,
uh,
omitted from the print listings is a,
yeah.
The show is actually called,
don't say cunt.
Oh,
with Paul and guys,
this is the one place where you're
not going to hear the word count.
Yeah.
So it kind of a Pronto for five minutes.
There'll be 45 minutes because as we
understand that Americans don't like the
word count.
Some Americans.
Yeah,
it's getting number.
That's what we'll,
yeah,
we'll get,
we'll get one.
Until that day there was a,
there's a bunch of women that
were trying to take it back.
Who Was it?
Was that the,
the guys we fucked girls.
I think it was,
they were trying to take it
back through trying to like you,
you know,
take that and cut back the word.
Well,
I think I'm very dead inside my head.
What's the matter,
David here?
David.
David's having this dry.
Oh,
it might,
it might have disconnected.
Yeah.
This is fun.
For the huge Amy.
I'll hook it up.
Did you go your okay.
You might plug in.
There's a little bit of an issue.
I feel like there's a
pressure differential.
That's a bird feeling.
You only have one ear on to,
Oh,
you're both of them on.
They got in mind.
Yeah,
I took it off because they
couldn't hear anything.
Check,
check,
check.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
a little.
No,
that's Paul.
Apparently.
I think check,
check,
check.
That's me.
I can hear now.
Okay.
There are going to be down.
Just something that somebody is in here.
Gremlins
monkeying with the fucking side.
We're not.
Hold on which one was being,
I'm going to just adjust our shelf.
This one.
Oh,
there you go.
Hold on one,
one,
one.
I hear me,
Dave.
There we go.
That's good.
So I always hear Dave.
So why,
why did you choose that
as your podcast title?
We're Canadians and a content is not as,
not nearly as bad and
Canada's really swear word.
Yeah,
it,
yeah.
I don't know what they need to put out.
Some sort of a periodic table of
the atomic weight of swear words
would be quite,
quite heavy but heavier
on the American version.
But here,
uh,
in America con actually just drop through
the crust of the earth and right down
to the core you will go
through the other side.
So I guess we just found
that patently ridiculous.
Well,
we use,
we like,
um,
you know,
we,
we grew up,
I grew up hearing the word a lot from my,
my dad.
What does your dad like?
Well,
not like much anymore.
He's dead.
Thanks.
So he died.
He died in [inaudible] 79.
Sorry Dude,
I didn't 79,
but no,
as I always say,
he was mad.
There are no better
parents than dead parents.
No,
they can't fuck you up anymore.
That's right.
But my dad was a real really fond
of that word and English Canadian.
He full Canadian.
But being Canadian is kind of like being
English a little bit on your money's
still.
And we get all the
English movies on English,
TV show we a pledge
allegiance to the queen.
And school,
you know,
and I still,
so it's still going on possibly.
Yeah.
And in our sleep,
so many good things about
Canada yet so many preposterous.
It's true.
It's the fact,
well,
the fact that a monarchy still exists at
all is preposterous as great on paper.
Yeah.
Well the monarchy,
even itself,
it's,
it's become Kardashians.
Refied well yeah,
like I love him,
but didn't they weren't they always,
I guess they were,
I mean,
what,
tell prince died days and,
yeah.
Or even just back to Henry the eighth.
What,
what maintained the,
the monarchy other than the fact that
people wanted celebrities and that was the
only celebrities they had.
Right.
And the priests and I think Henry,
they also had ass implants if I'm,
yeah,
cause he did.
Yeah.
Wow.
Good for him.
Progressive.
Yup.
So ahead of his time.
Yeah.
That,
that is an interesting thing.
It's like the Prince Charles Lady,
Di's saga was essentially one of
our first reality things to enjoy.
Yeah.
Yes.
That was madness when it happened.
It was so huge.
And then someone said,
well,
what if we just make housewives
in orange county royalty and a,
and you don't have to pay them as much
as the king and Queen and you can cancel
them.
Yeah.
Those shows are wonderful there.
I've never seen an episode
of any of their fascinating.
The Beverly Hills one is there was,
well,
there's different versions of them,
right.
And different versions.
You get to see the geographical creepiness
of like Atlanta is its own thing.
Yeah.
Atlanta is not a bad one.
The worst one was jersey.
They're fucking savage people.
My ancestors,
those fucking savage monkey
folk that live in the worst.
Anything cut the first of the version,
the worst of anything.
The worst.
Penicillin is the Jersey Penicillin.
You know,
CSI Jersey was terrible by the way.
Nah,
that doesn't exist.
Yeah.
I'm the Beverly Hills.
One of the,
all of them were
fascinating and it was take,
take people forced them in these
situations where they're going to have his
artificial disputes.
Well,
it was crazy to me is watching people
succumb to the pressure of all of that
attention.
Wouldn't,
they've never experienced it before.
And then you're going to just thrust
them into this massively popular,
you know,
for lack of a better word,
confessed.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
if you take your test fame,
yeah.
I need divorce it up.
Any supporting sort of supporting
under talent structure.
Yes.
Or didn't support,
sorry.
Nothing to offer.
No offering.
There's no painting,
no sculptor.
He's still singing.
They only take yes.
Give cause fame will destroy.
If you're a brilliant artist,
fame will destroy you.
If there's nothing underneath the fame,
it's this,
there's nothing to hold it up.
While I remember watching
Kelsey Grammer's wife,
I had met her before,
she seemed like a very nice lady.
Camille,
Camille.
And then she,
uh,
I forgot her name.
Thank you.
I didn't want to just contact owner.
He has a huge Camille Fan.
I have a tattoo.
I was gonna say,
do you have a tattoo?
But she decided to play the heel.
And the Prac,
it was so obvious that the
pressure was just overwhelming.
The hatred that was coming her way.
She had decided she was going to be
the boss bitch on the show and just let
everybody know,
you know,
this is how it is and I'm,
I'm here to run things and
just the swamp of evil.
That came her way and then she's like,
God quit done.
Fuck this show.
And she,
she bailed out of it.
Good for her.
Yeah.
It's even changed that role or was it
like a producer and said here's your,
well according to Kelsey he told her like,
Hey,
okay,
this is what you've always wanted here.
Like cause that's like what led to their
divorce or what was happening during
then them getting divorced,
you know,
and essentially said,
this is what you've always wanted.
Like don't think you understand this,
so go to the good luck with it.
And then you know,
she,
she just kind of vanished afterwards.
She's like,
fuck all this,
which is wise on her part.
She,
she,
she recognize what it is,
but they're like those,
those people that are on it.
Like,
I know some people who know some
folks that are on that show and it's,
they'd just go crazy.
They start to pop and pills
and losing their mind.
They're in therapy every
day and it's just madness.
Yeah.
That desire for fame with nothing more
to it than other than a desire to be
famous can only drive you insane.
Yeah.
Cause I think fame,
fame as a,
as an emergent property of doing
something right is bearable,
but it's products but so strange
and so difficult to truly manage.
But you can at least say,
I don't define myself by the fame.
I define myself by the
work that created the fame.
Yes,
yes.
Whereas if there's no work underneath it,
it's,
you know,
you only exist in so much
as people are aware of you.
You exist in those moments when you walk
into a room and everyone's staring at
you.
That's what you look for.
And that's that.
I have that anyway because of my body.
So I guess I know real famous.
Right.
And your and the horrible
allergy you have to pants.
True.
I can't wear pants.
Yeah.
Every time I walk in a room.
Well,
I always say like that,
that uh,
that fame is a property of the beholder,
not the beheld.
And that that fame only exists along long.
Somebody in the room knows who you are,
right?
In a minute,
you're in a room where no one knows you,
your fame evaporates.
That is one of the weirdest interrogations
I've ever gotten is when people go,
Woo,
why did these people know you?
What do you do?
Who are you and shit.
I know.
Yeah.
I take a photo with you there.
Where somebody,
but I don't know who they were.
Things.
They're almost defended that other
people know you and they go like,
why you're playing a game with me.
Why are you,
why?
Why don't I know you?
They get angry.
Yeah.
Well,
there also,
there's the other thing about famous that
people feel like they could just start
talking to you.
Yes.
Yeah.
They can sit next to you.
Oh yeah.
You could be in the middle of an intense
conversation with your favorite person
on the planet.
They don't give a fuck.
Why didn't I know you
haven't been in their house.
I had a living room.
I had a guy come to me in
the street and just go,
Hey Dave,
how you doing?
And I thought,
oh,
it must know him.
So he said,
oh,
I'm good.
How are you doing man?
And his next line was a,
you don't even know me.
You fucking phony,
David.
That was me.
That was you.
I wish I was better at faces.
Was this in Canada?
This was in downtown La.
Real.
It's amazing.
Even know me.
You fucking phony.
I'm just trying to be nice.
Yes.
Was he a drunk?
No,
he was just,
he was a guy who just,
uh,
let me go pretend I know him.
It just watch this.
Wow.
Was that the end of the conversation?
And that was basically it.
Wow.
What a rude person.
That's a terrible conversation.
Probably guy who auditioned for news
radio in [inaudible] 96 I've just never
gotten over it.
Yeah.
That fucking con one.
I was on my way to start
them and to be fair,
it was me.
Tripped him up.
Yeah.
Um,
are you still doing
that show with a doctor,
Ken?
No.
Uh,
we stopped when they canceled it.
Oh,
that's always a good move.
Yeah.
Not right away.
It's several months in a fairly good
kept doing the show after it was camp.
Yeah,
we didn't,
we did called the doctors.
Is that what it's called?
No,
no,
no.
That's a real one.
I can't remember.
What was the name of it again?
We can still call Doctor Oz.
A real doctor.
Right.
I don't think it's he's Fargo on is
drew once you've been pushed in front of
Congress.
Yeah.
And they question you on
your weight loss claims.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I had some Charlotte that you're show
it that had a crazy title or something,
wasn't it doctor?
Can't that was it doctor Ken?
He just did a Netflix special.
He did.
He's,
he's at back doing standup.
Yeah.
He's one of the sweetest
guys on the planet earth.
He is a nice man.
Very,
very nice guy.
And he's a,
yeah.
Got a lovely family.
Yeah.
Super good guy.
Um,
are you still doing the acting thing?
You can join it,
uh,
off and on,
you know,
enjoying difficult concept.
Well,
you always,
that was the take I had on it
with you back in [inaudible] 94.
It's a better job than most.
Yes.
You know?
You know,
like that and not like,
you know,
it's,
it's like when you're
doing something you'd like,
there's a certain satisfaction,
but even then,
even like when we were doing news radio,
you don't get to enjoy it because you're,
you're so focused on whatever the
flaws are while you're making it.
Right.
Yeah.
You get to enjoy it during the wrap party.
Or,
or 20 years later,
right?
Yeah.
I,
um,
it's occasionally someone will send
me a clip online and it's just,
it's so strange to watch.
It's so strange when you're watching
yourself from 20 plus years ago.
Say something you don't remember saying.
Yeah.
And then your watch,
like,
wow,
I don't even remember that episode at all.
Yeah.
I don't remember most,
I don't,
I never watched,
I think I only watched about six episodes.
Wow.
Is Radio.
Yeah.
And I loved the show.
But,
but you knew that he
didn't want to watch it.
You were there.
Yeah.
There what had happened.
Yeah,
yeah.
If I bought,
all they'd be doing is
nitpicking the editing.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a strange thing to
look back when you go back,
you know,
20 plus years and think of all the,
all the scenes,
all the writing,
all the work and now it's just sort of
now w w that's the other thing that we
never anticipated that it would
be floating around the Internet.
Yeah.
You know,
yeah.
Youtube clips,
nothing goes away.
And he's radius floating way out
in the periphery of the Internet.
Yeah.
But you see,
she was like drawn in sometimes,
but shows like,
like,
uh,
like friends,
like the fact,
you know,
you have young kids,
like my daughter's 15,
she's watched every episode
of friends at least twice.
Wow.
10 that's 10 years of shows.
And it's not just here,
it's every 15 year old in the country.
Yeah.
Has One.
And it's like that,
that,
you know,
is coming back into
significant to these kids.
Now,
what's fascinating is I don't think
those shows are being made anymore.
No,
not that.
Not like don't,
I mean there's the chuck Lorre
type shows that I watch and I go,
I'm missing a GM.
Why was like,
why is everyone laughing so hard to be
your seen those without the laugh track.
I can imagine that that
must be life taking some of
those shows and the Big Bang
theory and I would like to see that
they've removed the laugh track and you
watch it with just the act or sing the
words and it's like it's anything funny
ever happen on it.
Well it just,
it's strange.
It's like you're watching.
Um,
it doesn't make any sense.
It's a logical yeah.
And that,
that,
that place people get in their
heads where they just go,
it'll be fine.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
News radio,
if we did a scene and
it didn't get a laugh,
we rewrote the whole seat.
Yeah.
Literally with the audience there.
Well,
I think the term good enough
is perfect for comedy.
Yeah.
That's good enough.
People are kind of
chuckling while it's to you,
once you get a certain
number of characters that
you can get to interact with
each other and predictable
ways on those shows,
then they just sort of have them have
these little scenes and have different
inflections and different stumbles
and they make a show out of it.
And for the audience,
I think it just becomes comfort.
Familiarity.
I love it.
I maintain,
that's what drove Charlie sheen crazy.
It was doing that Goddamn show.
Yeah,
he did for a long time.
For a long time.
I think that's what drove him to the edge.
I thought.
I think he was always crazy.
But I think when you do a show that
you don't enjoy doing or that you don't
look,
the guy was in fucking platoon.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean he was in some amazing pharaoh.
He wasn't very funny in that.
No,
it wasn't.
It was really kind of a bummer.
Yeah,
they should.
Uh,
they should have taken that as a warranty.
Yeah.
They should take that company Lindelof
that that should stop ending up on all
those companies.
Wall Street.
I mean,
he was in some giant,
a good way,
the movies and then he's on the show.
That doesn't really make sense.
Right?
Yeah.
And he's really talented.
Like he's really,
really talented actor and really funny.
It's hilarious.
Like great timing.
Uh,
what was the,
uh,
like the,
like her brothers franchise,
uh,
hot shots.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It was funny in those,
they don't make those
kind of movies anymore.
Like nobody does jokes anymore.
It doesn't say,
Nah,
can't do jokes.
Effort is frowned upon.
Think you have to be lazy with
your comedy movies or you know,
there's still comedy movies,
right?
There's like the Judd Apatow
type films and you know,
there's still,
they still make comedy movies,
but there's seems like
there's not as many anymore.
Yeah.
Or maybe I just don't go out as much.
There's a little bit of that too.
Yeah.
But it's also like the subject
matter is so dangerous now.
Like everything that used to be funny,
we watched ace Ventura pet detective
with my kids and I did not remember how
transphobic that movie is.
Like the whole movie is
one gigantic Trans Joke.
It's true.
I don't know if I've ever seen it.
At the end of it,
I'm like,
Whoa,
I forgot.
This is crazy.
Like the men,
when they find that she's a girl,
they're throwing up and or
the that she's a boy rather.
There's the brushing teeth.
Yeah.
The scrubbing and mouth out.
Everyone's vomiting.
You wouldn't be skewered today.
You'd be finished.
Yeah,
it'd be done.
And they still,
that whole joke from the crying game.
Ugh.
That's true.
Which is one of the funniest
movies I've ever seen it.
Which one came first?
I don't know.
Any magic if the trunk crying game
did a serious version of Ace Ventura.
I feel like I have an idea.
Hey,
forgot about the crying get whole ass
talking scene would be totally different.
Yeah.
I thought,
I remember watching the crank game going,
uh,
and heard there's this big twist,
big surprise twist.
And that's the guy.
I bet.
What happens is that the,
that the,
the transvestite turns
out to be an IRA spy
because you were already two steps ahead.
Yo,
I forgot that movie.
Yeah.
So,
wow.
How long have you guys
been doing this podcast?
This is how long?
It's just before Christmas.
Yeah.
Probably each other.
We've known each other a lot.
Like what motivated our wives to say,
get the fuck out of here,
out of the house.
Pretty much that's it was go do
something new somewhere else.
And uh,
and they actually on the podcast with us,
like,
uh,
Chrissy,
my wife produces it and
puts it all together.
Jack Harris,
super hard to fire it.
Did well,
were the ones who will get fired.
He fired me once as a 10
years right now for pain.
But Chrissy and I were,
we separated for 10 years.
Well,
you,
well,
uh,
well actually last time I saw you
as well during that separation.
Um,
but uh,
so you got back together.
We got back together.
That's nice.
Yeah.
Course is great.
I remember running into her at a Satan
thing that the sate tannic fucking thing,
right?
Yeah.
Duncan Trussell,
my good friend was performing at,
uh,
is it Stanton [inaudible] grandson or
something like Anton liberties on the
Antis Branson and uh,
they,
they were getting married at this
fucking crazy theater and your wife was
dressed as like a devil or some shit.
She was like dancing there.
And I'm like,
oh,
hi.
How are you?
What are you doing here,
Carrie?
Normal person.
Why here?
But,
uh,
the,
there's a picture of me with a Antala
Bay that knuckle heads to this day uses
evidence that I am a station.
Satan worshiper.
You're merely an associate.
Satan associate.
I'm Satan to Jason's.
Yeah,
I think that's what they say now.
You know,
and that's fanboy.
I loved that.
That that's something people are,
you still worry about it.
I'm a Satan family.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
that's good.
It's me and a,
I think that's a Hank Williams,
the third shirt that I'm wearing there.
It's hard to tell.
That's the thing,
the fact that people still
worry about Satan is just,
you want to just say calm down.
He's not a problem.
Cause he doesn't exist just like your God.
Oh,
they both air you.
The people listening right now that just
took their earphones off and threw them
across the room.
Well,
I can hear cut for 30
times you say to that.
Yeah,
just that you know whether or not
God exists is a fascinating point of
discussion.
But what's interesting is,
is this agreement that people say when
they decide that God exists and you
decide that God exists and I decided to,
God exists.
So we both have agreed that there's this
weird thing that makes no sense that
we're on board with.
So I know where you
stand on a lot of issues.
You know,
I probably know where
you stand on abortion.
I probably know where you stand on guns.
I probably know where you
stand on climate change.
It's like he gets so weird little
thing that you do when you say that,
you know when you say,
well,
you know I'm a god fearing Christian.
Oh,
okay,
no,
I can predict you better.
It's like,
I swear it's like you're off.
You're all wearing the same decoder ring.
Yes,
yes.
Well that is what a lot of it is.
A lot of it is whether or not
you believe in God or not.
It's the saying that God's real and the
worshiping God and the talking about
God.
It's just letting everybody
know that they can predict.
You know,
they know where you kind of
like if you're a gentleman,
if you're a gentleman,
you wearing a tie with a nice
suit on and pair of pants,
I can fairly likely predict that
you're going to be reasonably behaved.
Yeah,
you're a gentlemen.
You know,
if you're a Christian,
if you're a person who calls
himself a Christian and you know,
well we go to the Bible,
go to church every Sunday and uh,
I'd like to read the
Bible and I am a Christian
and people automatically go,
oh,
okay.
I kind of know where you're coming from.
I can,
I can see where you are.
And now I like that you can predict to me,
cause you will like me better
so we don't have to talk.
Yes,
no.
All right.
Now reinforce those,
those patterns in your head.
And I'll say some things that,
uh,
I've repeated things that I've heard
other people say about God and Jesus and
yeah.
And it's a nice way to kill time.
It's not a bad way,
you know,
believing in God and
going to church and state,
it's a great,
you killed time until death
nullifies all meaning.
Well,
I think the community
thing of it is a good day.
There's,
there's some,
there's some really powerful like bonding
experiences that people have when they
agreed to be humbled together.
Yeah.
You know,
you're describing curling,
curling,
curling.
Another great look.
See Words in Canada are very popular.
Countering,
curling.
Yup.
That's right.
And there's no way he's
curling is one of the top TV.
And you cannot rise to the tops of
curling without humbling yourself.
Cause you humble yourself
the minute you say,
I'm not like go curly when you pick up
that brush and a big smile on your face
side to sweep.
I,
yeah,
I'm tried.
Curling man.
It's not easy.
No,
it's hard.
Which still doesn't make it a sport.
I made fun of it in Newfoundland
and they fucking got so mad at me.
Wanna curling.
He'll read a theater where I was at like
how these pictures of curlers on the
wall and I just could not
stop shitting on them yet.
We're like,
hey,
there were legitimately upset.
I'm like,
it is a preposterous endeavor.
Yeah.
You know in,
and I know it,
you're sliding a rock on the ice.
Used to be a reason to drink.
That's what curling was,
where everybody would get together,
still is wasted and you don't fall very
far on the ice because we're already
squatting.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And the other people are
leaning against brooms.
That's right.
You got a broom to lean against.
It's great you're drinking.
It's also like when you fall on ice,
it's almost always funny.
Always.
Yeah.
No one's,
no one ever catches himself.
No.
You don't like gently fall.
You could try and get up as good to you.
Don't fall elegantly on ice.
You can even go hiking and slip a
little and catch yourself in that.
But even like when you're watching the
NHL and you'll see players that will just
fall down.
Yeah.
Like just for no reason.
It's hilarious.
These are the best skaters in the world,
and they're just going
to fall down on his ass.
He's a professional airplane.
Yeah.
And like if I ran with it Volkswagen,
I couldn't knock him over.
Right.
But he just fell.
How long has curling been around?
Hundreds old.
It's a Scottish court.
It's a Scottish spot where they used to
use actual rocks they'd find in fields
and play it on frozen lakes.
The lakes,
because that's the only
kind they have in Scotland.
Yeah.
Are frozen ones and the
lochness monster can around.
There's a lot of,
he's a wonderful curler.
David,
are you Scottish?
I believe I'm from,
yeah,
I've got,
I got the part Scottish.
I mean,
there's a lot of Scottish
people in Canada,
so you can see what
curling would be popular,
you know,
very,
very Scottish country Canada.
It's strange.
That's why there's so many gourds and
Craig's or it ain't that Johnson Gordon
[inaudible].
Yeah,
that's right.
That would be a Scottish word,
right?
Yep.
Gordon Gordon.
Yeah,
and of course because of Gordie Howe,
everyone named their kids.
Gord.
I went to school with a
guy named Greg [inaudible].
I mean that was his first name.
Greg or Greg or I know a guy named Greg
or Gregory Gillespie fights in the UFC
animal.
I haven't kind of,
Gregor,
probably it's a savage.
Can I just give one interesting
UFC memory for me please?
I watched the very first UFC one a with,
I had a trip at the time and we
invited scout troop and it wasn't,
it was a comedy troupe,
this boy scouts,
but we invited Neil Patrick Harris over.
It was 20 years old at
the time he was in town.
We just met him and he came over
and soon as the sumo wrestler,
God has face kicked in and
there's spit a tooth out,
I believe.
He was like,
I'm Outta here.
I gotta get out.
And we made him stay and
watch the whole thing.
Good for you.
And that's what made him gay.
While that was,
thanks for ruining the story,
Dave.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if it works.
Something happened,
maybe someone dropped him on his head.
Yeah.
I don't think he knows.
He looked like he was already as a kid,
something went wrong or right.
Depending on if you as boyfriend.
Yeah.
Imagine it depends if
he's a good boyfriend.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
yes,
but I mean if the husband,
if the guy's really into him,
thank God you watch that fight,
that time.
God thank God.
Otherwise could have
never found time chick.
Yep.
Who knows.
Look at Abby's and shit.
Oh God.
Yeah.
So did you have to get remarried or did
you just pretend we never got divorced?
Chrissy and I never got
around to getting divorced.
Customer paperwork.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
So we were separated.
We,
we actually filed for divorce once,
but screwed up the paperwork for somehow.
Is that true?
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
and then,
and then we just never
got around to it again.
Just didn't fix it.
And we now islet.
Yeah.
I'm not,
you know,
I'm not good with organizing,
so we just,
so we were just separated for,
you know,
it's funny because Chris,
he's very organized.
She is yet,
it seems like maybe,
maybe Jackie,
Jackie,
she's the one who wasn't
willing to let go.
You know,
she was telling you something.
Yeah,
she was there early
and that's what,
that's what,
yeah,
that's what guys will
be vacation with them.
When they were divorced,
divorced.
They would go as a together and
we get all our family trips.
Did they,
did all family tree the
whole table together?
Well the first two years we
weren't that we didn't do much.
No.
Those are the dark years.
The dark.
Yes.
But then uh,
yeah,
then yeah,
that's why we have kept me in
all of our family trips together.
We go to Hawaii.
It's like they were still married.
Yeah.
And so when we finally did get back
together it was really just so,
it was mostly about the
convenience of our friends.
It was just like,
you know,
this is going to make
everyone else's life easier.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause they don't,
you know
what,
we didn't have to go to two houses.
Yeah.
Which I hated.
It's so Canadian of you.
Yeah.
So polite Canadian does.
Yup.
He's
doesn't get divorced because the fly.
How long,
how long have you been married?
10 years.
And you,
that's the only time
you've ever been married,
right?
Thank the baby Jesus.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Praise Jesus.
Done that.
It's working.
Yeah,
it's,
it's great.
Yeah.
If it works,
it's great.
Yeah.
I always tell people,
don't do it.
It's too risky.
Yeah.
You could.
50% of the people don't make it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's uh,
it's not a good,
a good rate of success.
Would you drive a car if you knew that
50% likely you would die in a crash,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
it was an institution that made sense
when you're only going to live to be 40
sweat.
Well,
it makes sense.
There's some parts of it that makes sense.
The problem is that it's become a business
and it's become a business for people
to try to squeeze is like,
I'll never forget trying to talk,
fill in and getting divorced.
Yeah.
I go,
just give her half.
And he goes,
it's not half.
It's two thirds.
It's a scam.
The fucking lawyers get a third.
Yeah.
He gave away two thirds and then he
was fucking freaking out about it.
And it's true.
And he could've lived nicely on the third.
He should have given her that.
I don't think that,
I mean,
the word was that,
that's why she killed him,
that he was leaving,
that that was,
he was finally leaving,
and then that's when she killed him.
But when we were together with him,
there was always days where he would
come to the set and just be just in hell.
Oh yeah.
Well,
yeah.
And he wouldn't well be,
he'd just be on the floor of
the studio and like ranting.
Yeah.
About,
about,
you know,
I'm living in my boat
and he lived in his boat.
It was rough,
man.
And then he would come back
like a day later and it'd be,
well,
I'm back together with my blushing bride.
That's exact quote.
Yep.
And we can the exact quote
and we'd all just be going,
oh yeah,
it was poor bastard.
Although none of the weird thing of news,
right.
There was not one good
marriage on the show.
You know,
like everyone was going through
a terrible marriage at the time.
Like I was proud that it was one
person who wasn't on antidepressants.
Super psyched about that.
I wasn't on any pills
and I wasn't in therapy,
but I probably needed it.
I think we all did.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I mean I remember you started with,
I can just this second season we came
back and Steve Route had gotten divorced
and he was the first one.
I mean,
I think everyone free to be me or
Phil would get divorced for us.
Steven Mora.
But Steve,
yeah.
We didn't know how bad it was for Steve.
I guess it's hard up there.
Tarred Todd to make it hard,
hard for people sit together.
It'd be nice to each other.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It takes,
does they say it takes work,
but it actually takes work.
Yeah,
it does take work.
Your way to wait until you
are an adult too is good.
Good move.
Yeah.
Most people get married
before they're adults.
Yeah.
I think you should wait until
you know who the fuck you are.
And it's still,
I'm still guessing.
Yeah.
Even to this day,
I'm guessing who I am.
Literally my dad almost on his
death bed told me don't do it.
You can't get married until
you're 30 that's a good move.
It's demanded that he,
I didn't,
I haven't got married
at 30 but he was like,
don't do it.
Don't do it before 30 cause
you don't know who you are.
You don't know what's going on.
Well that I've seen too
many predatory marriages.
I've seen women marry men
that don't really like,
because they know the man has money.
And I've seen,
I've seen the opposite.
It's just such a weird thing when you
enter into contractual agreement about
romance.
Like it's,
it's,
it's not just I love you,
you love me,
let's,
let's have a celebration of our love and
let's invite our friends over and tell
everybody we've,
we've decided to engage each other
in this very special commitment.
But then you start bringing in lawyers.
Yeah.
Right.
And then it gets weird.
And then you know,
you have weird state by state laws
where there's common law marriages.
If you live with someone for 10 years,
and that might've been where humanity
went wrong was when the first guys said,
I wouldn't be a lawyer.
Like that was his decision.
I'm looking around and to think,
yeah,
there's a lot of ugliness in the world.
Yeah.
What was the work on?
It was the first lawyer like was the,
there's a series of laws,
right?
The first lawyers had
to have been priests,
right?
I would guess so.
Yeah.
I mean the law is a
Ferris initially we're,
we're basically lawyers,
right.
What does a Pharisee,
the Jewish,
the Jewish priests makes sense.
That does make a lot of sense.
Yeah.
A lot of my relatives.
Like when did it become a thing where
it was you would go to law school and it
was,
uh,
a respectable occupation and it
would be good to know a good lawyer.
Yeah.
I think those things started out as not
respectable and people did them cause
they didn't have any other like choice.
And again,
they realized all their
making all the money,
you know,
and then it became respectable.
Well,
once they figured out there's all those
legal ease and loopholes in the system
is ways to extract money.
Yeah.
You just gotta be weasley about it and
then they invent a whole language to
exclude anyone else from understanding it.
Yeah.
Do you think they billed hourly back then?
Still?
Yeah.
But then again,
time hadn't been codified,
so,
so what did they built by an hour?
It was basically decided
by community standards.
You know,
when was time codified?
Uh,
when the railroads came in.
True.
Well that's when,
that's when time zones were created.
The time zones were
created by the railroads.
Really.
Everybody's on a different
time zone and every town,
every town said its own time.
Like wow.
Like you could have,
you could drive,
you could drive from like,
uh,
from Denver to Fort Collins and the two
cities would be completely different
times.
Wow.
And how you sync up your
watch with the town clock?
Yeah.
You have the clock in the main
square and that'll be all the time.
That's the time.
But when they started having
to schedule railroads,
they realized,
well,
Huh,
all these towns.
And then they started
having huge competitions to
invent ways of synchronizing
clocks between cities and that,
did they use a sun dial to
get the initial reading?
I think it really was just a simple as
we'll call this midnight or we'll call
this noon,
you know,
and then he just went from there and
none of the clocks were that accurate.
So time would shift over time.
So,
uh,
it became,
that was like in like the 19th century
was a huge move to try and find a way to
synchronize clocks.
And that drove,
kind of drove a lot of the
beginnings of technology.
Do you remember when you were a kid you
would call phone number to get the time?
Always say yes for sure the exact time.
The weather as well sometimes.
But the time,
the time is exactly
four 59 and 35 seconds.
Well,
and in Canada at one o'clock every day
they had the national time tone right at
this essential and of the long
beep it will be exactly one PR,
radio and TV.
Why 1:00 PM?
I don't know why,
but it has.
When they would do it
at 1:00 PM every day,
the CBC would,
would broadcast a tone
and that was the time
for the whole country.
Wow.
I never would've guessed that time
zones are created by the railroads.
Yeah,
but it totally makes sense.
Have a schedule without,
yeah.
Because before that nobody went anywhere.
You know,
Arizona's still doesn't
do daylight savings time.
They're like,
fuck you.
That's stupid.
They're allowed to do that.
Yup.
Wow.
If you drive from like if you
drive from Nevada to Arizona,
you're,
you miss an hour.
Yeah.
The act.
The only state.
Isn't there another state that doesn't,
I wonder,
I think no one I'm aware of.
Is there a wide why Hawaii?
They're an island.
We stole Hawaii.
Yeah,
that's right.
Doesn't that island is theirs.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a fucking country
that we occupy with hotels.
It's own feeling.
The rest of it was given to us by God.
Yes,
that's true.
It's manifest destiny.
Correct?
Yes.
The rest of it,
but not Hawaii.
No.
Cause that came less late.
It was late.
The game.
There's no single co like there's no
state where the people are so clearly like
their ethnicity is so clearly defined.
They're Polynesian
looking at both the lay,
their culture,
North Dakota or fucking
Florida or some shit.
It's like they're not from
the European heritage.
No.
Yeah,
there's,
you know,
there's an interesting debate going on
about what is ne or California moves
towards permanent daylight savings time.
It's not your land
every day.
We get to get up an hour early every day.
Earlier and earlier and
earlier and earlier.
I already of Arizona's on permanent
standard time and the year lown daylight
savings times followed by Hawaiian and
the territories of the American Samoa.
Oh,
Guam and minor outlying islands.
While I say California,
let's be really bold and go for permanent
daylight look like a white Alaska,
Alaska.
Exactly.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's just give up on night.
Well,
and then just everybody wants to kill
themselves when it's nighttime there.
There's an interesting debate going on
in Hawaii right now as to what is an
invasive species because so much of the
wildlife in Hawaii was brought over and
so there's,
there's some debate on certain islands
where they want to eliminate the wild
pigs because they say they're an
invasive species and then the people are
saying,
but we'll hold on because we kind of
came after a lot of these wild pigs.
Like a lot of the wild pigs
were dropped off by pirates,
like carrots and,
and people that were in a boating like
that were traveling by boat across the
world.
They would drop off goats
and pigs on various islands,
so they would have something to hunt when
they would come back for food because
they knew that this would
be a stop along their route,
which is clever.
It is clever.
It ruined a lot of islands,
especially the goats.
Yeah.
Destroyed a lot of islands.
I just ate it.
And now in Hawaii there's
a lot of mongoose.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They brought Mongoose and at
some point I forget what it was,
was,
was to control the rabbit population.
That was probably where the rats,
I think it was to control that
as they came in from again,
from shipping and then the
mongoose probably starting another.
Anything else?
Just all over the place.
Yeah.
Mongoose animals under the Alaska
holiday and I made a joke about,
you know,
I'm looking for beavers cause I didn't
think there were beavers in Alaska
because it's too cold.
They said no last 10 years we've got
tons of beavers here cause of global
warming.
Reelers everywhere.
Yeah,
they're moving.
Beavers are migrating north.
Yeah.
Alaska is a fascinating place that
you could go there for the summer.
You go there in the summer,
you have never seen more
aggressive mosquitoes.
It's like they know they only have two
months to live and so you get out of your
car,
they swarm,
you look a cloud.
It's crazy.
I've never seen anything
like it in my life.
You would think tropical weather,
that's where the mosquitoes.
Yeah.
No Alaska.
They're fucking ferocious
and they're huge.
Yeah.
I've never actually going to go there.
And then in November I think.
Oh yeah.
What are you doing during
the touring with a,
whose life anyway?
It's like an Improv tour.
So who's live anyway?
Like a takeoff shoot.
Who's line is it anyway?
It's like Greg Proops and Jeff
Daniels from that show and a,
yeah.
So Greg and Geoff and Jo Marie.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
And me,
I guess Joe,
Mary's Bill.
Murray's brother,
right?
Yeah.
So it's like a rotating,
uh,
so those three guys at the core,
and then there's a,
uh,
Ryan stiles myself,
drew Carey and uh,
and chip esten sort of rotate through,
likes it.
The tour to carry might be the
nicest person that's ever lived.
I don't know him well.
He might be the nicest guy ever.
And it's nice he,
yeah,
I remember it was the drew Carey show
that finally got Newsradio canceled,
Huh?
Nope.
No,
remember we did a whole year after that,
but I think that was what it was.
I don't think they wanted
to do it anymore after that,
but I think our waiters
are ratings tanked when we,
when they put us up against true
care or ratings are always shit.
Yeah.
That's the most amazing thing is
that the ratings were really great.
Once we got canceled
and then it was on TV,
like they would show the reruns.
So people go,
oh,
this is a funny show.
They,
they found it.
It's true.
I remember Lou Morton,
uh,
one of our writers showing
up at the huge show,
but the read table read the different
number on his shirt every week when we
were in the real shit or
when we're falling apart.
The lowest number nine,
eight out of a hundred shows,
eight was one day,
no bullshit.
I go,
is that real?
He's like,
yeah,
like have the shirt made?
Yeah.
No,
you would draw it basically.
It basically a sweatshirt
with a marker on it.
That's hilarious that he would just
show up with this fucking number on his
shirt and I was like,
hey.
He's like,
yeah,
it's a source of pride when
you can still be hanging on.
One year that I thought we weren't going
to get canceled was the year we got
canceled.
I was like,
well,
we're doing pretty good.
Yeah.
Well actually I have a ratings.
We're all right.
Yeah,
it's a five year show.
Right.
But much like the whole,
like we never really
hit a hundred episodes.
We got to like 97 97
because NBC didn't own it.
So they did that with a bunch
of shows they didn't own.
They do that on purpose for a year,
but four or five shows they
cancelled at 97 episodes.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause they,
cause there's,
it's a hundred it goes into syndication.
Is that right?
It used to be the rule.
Yeah.
But now syndication,
anything doesn't really exist anymore.
Well the weirdest one was the Charlie
Sheen model that they did with that anger
management show where they divided
the whole new system 10 yeah.
If the first couple
episodes do well fuck it,
we order a hundred and they
produced them all in the year.
Yes.
They just saw mashed them together.
They just,
they wrote it within five
minutes and started filming,
filming and writing on the fly.
Everything was dog shit.
And they shot like four episodes a week.
They paid Charlie in cracks.
Yeah.
Thousands of dollars with
a crack and do his account.
Yeah.
They had one of those old timey ice guys
that you still have her ice delivered
the crack thing to his door cause you,
cause here's the thing,
they have themselves.
You can't get crack out
of an ATM machine yet.
No,
not anymore.
And you can get pot out of one now.
Yeah.
You can get pot out of a dispensary.
Michigan,
California.
That's good.
Yeah.
Well I don't know where we'll see.
We'll find out.
But there's,
there's,
they do have marijuana
dispensary machines.
Yeah.
You must have to like show
some sort of a proof of age.
But I guess if you just have your,
if you have a passport,
a passport or a driver's license,
like if you could read a passport,
they have a machine that reads
a passport at the airport.
You know when you go through,
if you have like um,
global entry,
they got the face recognition
thing until I got the clear.
Yeah,
I got that fingerprint one.
That's nice too.
Yeah.
Glover entries the best dog.
You don't have to fuck
with that giant lawn.
Yeah.
Just shit ain't got that.
I got this stupid Tsa global entry is
great because it comes with TSA pre.
Yeah.
I get the Tsa and they get the clear ad.
It makes me mad.
The ultimate Combo is Tsa pre and clear.
Yeah.
Cause they just do the fingerprints.
Boom.
And then they'd push
it right into the line.
Sounded like venereal disease
and nice people walk you.
They walk you all the way.
10 clear,
clear not to pit Tsa pre with clear,
the nice people walk you
all the way over to the,
but yeah,
you can't,
the person you have the option of
actually pissing on the people that you're
passing on their feet because
they don't have any shoes on.
My God,
I have to get this.
Yeah,
that sounds fantastic.
I'm going to get that.
But then it,
yeah,
I'm gonna go out to the company.
You have to travel.
So no,
not much.
I mean to Canada,
but that doesn't really matter.
It's something country.
Yeah.
We will still in this country.
Well you could always go through
through the woods you had to Canada.
It's true.
People who taught border the border is a
hundred a hundred yard clearcut is most
of the border with Canada is just a
hundred yard clearcut and in the forest.
So it's,
it's actually cut cutting the trees down.
It's like a hundred yards wide
and that's the border all across.
It's not from what entity?
Natalie's it,
it's actually easier to cross the
border then the surrounding area.
Yeah.
Because the surrounding areas though.
Forest.
Yeah.
No.
Do they,
do they actually maintained that cut?
Yeah.
Really.
So every year someone's job is to cut
down the trees for a hundred yard space
between the United States and Canada.
Yeah.
Why is most of the Canadian
border just still that?
You know,
if you're a criminal and you cross here,
additional charges will apply.
Yeah.
Cause now you've fled the country.
Well,
have you ever seen the,
you've seen the footage of,
of refugees coming into Canada and the
mounties meeting them and they were like,
the mounties are just,
they're going now you understand that
when you cross over here we will be
arresting you.
There is look at the best of life.
Wow.
That's crazy.
The 49th parallel,
it says,
yeah.
Wow,
that's fucking crazy.
I bet that's a,
you need to passports to
watch the there there America,
there's where your terror should
last the opposite of a wall.
Yeah.
That's an actual welcoming pants actually.
That shows how much we like Canada.
Yeah.
Or how little you think about it.
Make it easier to cross.
We'll make it really super easy.
It's easier than the 100 yard stretch.
It's like,
ah,
don't trip a really relax yourself.
You're about to hit paradise.
And most,
most of the visa overstays or Canadian,
which is the bulk of illegal
immigration in America,
is Canadians overstaying their visas.
Right.
I've done that.
Yeah.
It's a giant part of it,
right?
I mean,
we all overstay our welcome
call British folks too.
Definitely.
Yeah.
But no one cares.
But the thing is they
don't think about Canada.
There's a lot of people in this country
from a lot of other countries that just
keep your fucking mouth shut.
Yeah.
No one knows.
Like when,
whenever they say they know,
like they take an estimate on how
many illegal aliens might vats.
Yes,
no.
Yes.
Guest.
Yeah.
Well it's Kinda like,
well,
just thinking you actually had,
uh,
was it,
Brian Cox on?
Yes.
And he said when to talk about the,
the uh,
the size of the universe.
Yes.
Most of it's just a guess based
on the observable universe,
based on the number of
galaxies they can see.
They're just guessing and
how many galaxies there are.
I think that's the same as
the illegal immigration.
You're just going,
well,
if we can be more likely to be accurate
with a illegal immigration than you are
with stars.
I don't know.
Yeah.
I think the star thing,
the problem is,
I'm,
I'll butcher this,
but I think it's that literally we don't
have the capability to look past 13
point whatever billion years.
Yes.
The big band really look.
Yeah.
So if they look and they go,
oh no,
on,
there's just like a big space and then
you go 18 more billion years back,
there was a thriving
community of galaxies,
galaxies,
that's distance and time.
But then the,
just the sheer vastness of the sky,
they've only actually like,
like looked at a fraction of it.
Well,
talking to a guy like him is so
amazing because you realize like,
okay,
well there's different kinds of humans.
Yeah.
There's,
there's humans that are actually studying
these insanely complicated equations
that are trying to prove that the
very nature of reality itself.
And then there's champs like me
who are just listening going,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
So Real,
real big.
Yeah.
Okay.
How do we know it started?
There was a bang.
Okay.
What started the Bang Mr Smarty pants,
but I guess Brian Cox,
he's,
he's innovative and that
he is an astrophysicist and
he looks like a young David
Cassidy and he's a musician.
Musician it,
yeah.
He's,
he's dreamy.
Yeah.
He's a great guy to have a crush on.
I had a crush on him too.
Oh my gosh.
Super Sweetheart of a guy too.
Like not just never met him,
but I love watching him on TV.
I did his podcast once,
the live version of it,
which is interesting.
It was great.
And he apparently has a new show that's
coming here that I'll go with his
[inaudible] come with.
Yeah,
I'd love to.
It's,
um,
he has a gigantic screen behind him
filled with interlocking led screens that,
uh,
apparently it's like this unbelievably
gorgeous high definition version of the
cosmos.
So,
and it's created by the same
people who did that movie with,
uh,
which one?
Interstellar.
No,
it was created by it.
And it's like accurate,
like the,
the CGI is actually accurate.
Wow.
According to his type of equations.
Yeah.
He worked at Cerner and you know,
he's like,
he's amazing.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
And he's legit.
Beautiful Man.
Yeah.
Wow.
Nice.
That's funny.
David Cassidy was that,
he was an abandoned the eighties.
Oh yeah,
no,
he was a legit rockstar.
Yeah.
I mean,
genius.
Rockstar.
Yeah.
Good luck guys.
That guy was trying to fuck your wife.
You've got a real problem.
I think he was in [inaudible].
Yeah.
I think,
is that what the band was?
I don't know.
Just make that up so much.
That shirt,
that wire astrophysicists,
getting cuter.
I mean,
yeah.
you start with Stephen
Hawking and then you get to,
what's his name?
Green,
right?
Neil degrasse Tyson.
He's a handsome man.
That's a fellow.
And charming.
Sure.
Yeah.
Good laugh.
You didn't have to be pretty in the old
days position of science communicator is
so effective.
It's so important because most of that
stuff is so dry and so difficult to wrap
your head around.
But you don't need someone,
someone,
a Carl Sagan.
Yes.
Someone engaging,
they can deliver that.
So like with,
with Brian,
he's so nice like that as he's,
he's like so smiley and
he enjoys it so much.
He loves talking about it so much that
it becomes infectious cause there's a lot
of that stuff that's very difficult to
follow when you try to read the papers.
I read for Stephen Hawking books and I
would zone out so much while I was trying
to comprehend what was going on.
I had Lawrence Krauss on and a,
I was trying to get him to explain,
um,
some certain formulas and just,
even when he's explaining them to you,
it doesn't seem to click like you,
you really have to,
it's one of those things you,
it's like someone trying to explain French
words to you by only speaking to you
in French.
Like,
okay,
but I don't speak French.
And you're like,
yeah,
well you're fucked.
Like soon as you say infinity that
that's only a mathematical idea.
Yeah.
I mean how can anything be infinite?
I mean,
I know,
well there's minute math you can say it.
Like you can say that a straight line
goes on forever and two parallel lines
will never intersect.
Pi As there theoretically,
you know it never ends well why
is that difficult to grasp though?
That's the real question.
Like why is,
why do we need everything to be defined
by a very obvious beginning and an end?
Cause it's in everything we experienced
has the beginning of that biologically
as we expand as time,
even in that time doesn't,
is not experienced
everywhere the same way.
Well,
time is experienced at all.
If you're not sentient true
or what is tire Zona there,
whack it off.
It's different.
But yeah,
it's the,
I always wondered if like there was a
reason why we wanted things to have a
beginning and an end.
Like is it because we have our life and
our life has a beginning and an end all
the lives of the people we know or we
definitely are obsessed with a beginning
or an end or are we terrified of
beginnings and ends thought too.
That's why we create,
you know,
God's and religions is because the idea
that that life ends and that it's all
been for nothing,
she's terrifying to people.
There's a little bit of that.
Yeah.
There's a little bit of like doing it
to create order in the community and
there's a little bit of people find
mushrooms and they need an explanation.
What the fuck their feelings.
Again,
brains are constructed in such a way
that we need an end or else you don't
understand.
Where am I now?
I have,
there's no end,
a very uninformed theory,
which is that
first off that everything is meaningless
but that only the brain damaged or
capable of conceiving of meaninglessness
because our brains are meaning machines
and that we evolved and it gave us an
evolutionary advantage that we give
meaning to things.
Like I said,
this is a table because
we say it's a table.
It's not a table to a cat.
That's why cat will just get up and walk
around on it from a mutual agreement.
Yeah,
we agree.
This is a table.
And that kind of meaning
let us organize our lives,
let us be better hunters.
Uh,
you know what?
You know it constantly,
it occurs to me and bothers me,
is that we decided not to drive into
each other because we've painted a little
line on a road now in the middle.
Yeah.
We've all agreed not to cross that line.
That's what I'm saying.
We ascribe meaning to objects and that
gave us an advantage over other animals.
And so our brains just evolved.
And then when we got to the point
where we realize we're going to die,
we go,
well,
there's gotta be some meaning there too.
So then we had to create myths that
where do we go created meeting about our
lives?
That's a very dangerous loop of there's
no meaning to everything and nothing has
no mean nothing has meaning.
That's a dangerous loop for a person
psychologically because you can get stuck
in that and you can really,
but I don't think you can because it's
impossible to conceive of unless you are
seriously brain damaged.
Well,
no,
I don't think it's impossible to conceive.
It's,
it's,
you won't,
you can imagine,
you can intellectually think about it,
but you can't,
you can't grasp it.
Really living in the now kind of
the same as life has no meaning,
no office sing about the future.
Thinking about,
you're not thinking about the
fact that it has no meaning.
You're enjoying life,
you're enjoying experience,
you're enjoying each interaction with
people and you're enjoying your thoughts.
I think the,
the,
the problem that people have is like,
what's the point?
That's the problem.
That,
what's that?
What's the point?
Thought?
And that's a weird loop.
And that's the thing is it doesn't really
matter because you're going to create
a point anyway.
Like,
I mean it's like there's,
I was an existential psychology they had,
there's like five different ways people
ascribe meaning metaphysical meaning
reproductive meaning,
biological meaning uh,
or creative meaning like
the works you do right,
that somehow you live on and all these
different ways you're like a lot of
atheists are tend to be
artists who believe that they
live on through their work
and which is totally a
stupid is believing in God.
It is.
It's definitely silly.
I mean obviously someone's going to enjoy
your work but I think the real meaning
is in creating the work and then the
fact that people are going to enjoy it if
you're doing it because you
want it to live on forever,
you're a moron and good luck
with that because there's no,
there's no forever the whole planet,
but I just think meaning is an
inescapable product of the human mind.
The example,
one example is like,
like they did a study where they went all
like into the jungles of the Amazon to
people who have never had any contact
with the modern world and they drew a
circle with two dots and a curved
line and everyone sees a face.
Hmm.
Everyone sees a face.
The only people who don't see a face or
people who have been brain damaged and
can no longer form the
meaning of those lines.
Oh,
interesting.
So you,
there are people who suffer brain does
not correspond to their own artwork
because like the,
our work is very similar to our artwork
and the fact that stick figures and they
represent humans and the
circle or does that's ahead.
Yeah.
All that stuff.
But they probably haven't
had the happy face tee shirt.
I had lunch with Erich
von Daniken last week.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Very interesting.
Very weird.
He's the guy who wrote
chariots of the gods.
He's in his eighties now fuck their house.
And uh,
he was showing us slides.
What's the real story there?
I was wondering mostly nonsense,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
Mostly.
Mostly what it is as evidence of law,
civilizations,
ancient civilizations that
were incredibly advanced.
I follow the work of Graham Hancock and
Randall Carlson and a few other people
that are being proven actually
correct more and more,
almost on a daily basis
by new discoveries.
It show that the,
that civilization predates
what we initially thought,
that the initial thought was that
somewhere around the great pyramids,
which is like 2,500 BC,
that was about as good as anybody got.
And you go back to like ancient Sumeria,
which is about 6,000 years ago.
And then that's basically it.
What they're saying is that no,
there was most likely a reset,
a global reset of civilization
due to a cataclysmic disaster.
And there's a shit ton of evidence.
There's massive evidence in the form
of this nuclear glass that exist when
there's asteroidal impacts.
And,
um,
also there's a guy named doctor Robert
Schoch is of the first guys to propose.
This is actually when he
freaked me on the podcast.
He said there was a mass coronal ejection
that most likely caused lightening
storms like a rainstorm,
but lightning like that much lightning
destroying the Glam and that the only
people that survived were people that
could get under cover that could get into.
Yeah and the mass extinction of 60 plus
percent of the large mammals in a very
short window of time almost
instantaneously in North America.
The the end of the Ice Age,
like 10,000 plus years ago there was a
mile high ice in most of North America,
right?
Most of North American covered in
ice and then gone and all these,
all these areas,
all these points of
interest point to this one,
one moment in time.
That's somewhere between 10 and 12,000
years ago that some big event happened
and that most likely just
crippled civilization and
then people had to rebuild
whatever people were around
on that because it's also
that they found like just
looking at DNA that all of humanity at
one point got wiped out except for like
one village that there
was only that everyone is,
everyone has
descended from the same
group of about 5,000 people.
That's well,
there was a super volcano that erupted
somewhere around 70,000 years ago.
They think this is predating
this cataclysmic disaster
of 12,000 years ago that
they are pretty sure wiped human
beings down to a few thousand folks.
Oh yeah.
I want to say it's,
where's that?
That super volcano,
there's,
there's a supervolcano that
knocked everybody down.
We'll find it.
Yeah.
We've got one under Yosemite,
right.
Call Dara is going to get us
all every six to 800,000 years.
It blows.
Right.
That's why I don't go camping.
That's might not be the worst place to go.
Like go camping.
Yeah.
That way when it ends,
it ends quick.
You don't want to be living in New York,
which was choking on it.
That's the worst.
Watching people eat homeless
folks in the street.
Yeah.
There's no,
uh,
there's now in a place.
Yeah.
Well,
it's awesome.
I'm like,
things that fly through space and zip by,
you know,
like they're,
they're just constantly
finding these things.
That's the lights things,
the Erich von Daniken thing.
I remember as a kid going,
my problem was that they kept showing
these massive paintings that can only be
seen from the sky.
So therefore there must have been
John for your aliens and I can,
you know,
if you believe God is looking down on you,
you're going to draw a big
paintings for God to look at.
So you don't need that.
But now,
right.
But now I'm more,
the,
uh,
thing I've become obsessed with lately
is there's a skepticism about Ufos.
Yeah.
That's why I want to talk to you about
this because you told me that you've
become obsessed with Ufos recently.
Oh yeah.
Completely.
And it's like,
yeah,
totally.
Really?
Yeah,
totally believe the
UFO phenomenon is real.
I don't know what it is,
but it's totally,
it has to be real.
Some things happened.
Why is that?
Because there's just way too
much evidence that it is real.
What evidence?
Uh,
well,
uh,
radar evidence,
that the,
the [inaudible] locked on a Ufo,
that footage and also just,
uh,
like I know that friend of ours,
I don't know if she wants to say it,
but her father was an air traffic
controller and he told her,
they said,
yeah,
every air traffic controller
has seen something.
Yeah.
And I had another friend whose father
was in a commercial pilot and she said,
yeah,
my dad said every single pilot has seen
something and they've all been told not
to say anything about it.
We have a couple of friends
that say they were abducted.
Yeah.
The abducted one is a little easier to
wrap your head around because when you're
sleeping,
your brain is producing all sorts
of indogenous psychedelic chemicals.
Yeah.
Almost all of these experiences
happen when you're sleeping.
Almost all of these experience,
when these people were abducted,
they're taken from their beds,
which is when they're dreaming.
I mean,
it's just like there's some real clear,
easy steps to follow up on a fall,
Occam's razor and not,
you're not get crazy,
but it knocks those out,
but it doesn't knock out like Barney and
Betty Hill and all the people that are
abducted will fully conscious and
that and that remember it without
hypnotherapy.
I'm like,
I'm not sure about
the abduction phenomenon,
but I don't know Barney and Betty Hill.
I know the story,
but I don't know them,
so I would have to know them because
there's a lot of people that I've taught,
like I did a show for Scifi,
I called Joe Rogan questions.
Everything that cured me.
It show cured me of a
lot of my nonsense with,
with conspiracies when
we used to talk about,
yes.
Yeah,
that's definitely him all the time.
yeah.
But I,
I needed to actually study it.
So for six months,
that's basically all I did.
I interviewed people and
I like big foot believers,
Ufo believers.
And the one thing that they have in
common is they all seem to be kind of lost
and dependent upon this thing being real.
Yeah.
Instead of being objective.
There's only one lady that I interviewed
that saw big that really seemed to be
telling the truth,
but I think she saw bear bear's
walk on two feet all the time.
They do it all the time.
It's video footage,
you to find it all the time.
And she was in the Pacific northwest,
which is incredibly dense woods.
You see something,
you glimpse it.
Look I was hunting once in,
in,
in Canada and Alberta and I thought
I saw a wolf for like two seconds.
It was a squirrel.
Okay.
Understand this.
This is fucking not squirrel.
Yeah,
no I just saw far right.
I saw for cause it's really dense was
cause I was looking for fucking wolves
cause I was like,
cause I know we did see one wolf.
It cross the roads.
Either wolf or coyote was hard
to tell cause it was at dusk.
It was very dark out.
But um,
when you're looking for something,
you think everything is that
thing you're looking for.
Yeah.
So for like a,
for a second,
huge thought that fucking
squirrel was a wolf.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Well the expectation and
perception are very linked.
Yes.
Well this us that they found that that
50% of everything you see is a product of
memory.
Yes.
That,
that when you observe something,
they've done frm Mris and that most
of the activity in the brain is in the
memory centers,
not in the,
uh,
visual sneakers.
Interesting.
Only about 50% of the activities,
individual centers of the brain.
That's crazy.
Well,
the
thing is very,
I,
when I was a kid,
I went and saw Carl Sagan speak at u of
t at the University of Toronto and I was
like,
you know,
14 but he did an equation on the board
of the possibility of alien life other
than us in the universe.
And it came to the smallest.
I mean,
he spent the whole time
writing on this chalkboard.
It was fascinating.
They actually came up with a number
at the end and it was such a small,
he says there is,
there is something out there,
but they are so far away that they'll,
that unless they can go faster
than the speed of light,
which he said was impossible at the time.
Yeah.
The Seventies.
Uh,
there's no way we've seen them.
That's what he said.
So if some other beings have
conquered speed of light thing,
then maybe we could see them.
Yeah.
But that's a thing with the exact problem
with his skepticism in general is like
a,
that it,
you know,
like,
like the skeptics,
skeptics of the,
of the 19th century,
the ones who said germs don't exist.
Right.
Cause we can't see them.
And,
and people who said germs did exist were
ridiculed and laughed out of the trade.
Right.
And I agree with you completely.
Just because you can't see
it or it isn't happening.
It doesn't mean it can't happen.
And even since Sagans Day be,
there had been no exoplanets
discovered then we now though,
there are literally trillions and
trillions of sure planet earth,
like planets.
Yeah,
well they just speculate
as to the existence of them
outside of our sources and
before the,
the real problem is that if some,
there's a leap and a leap,
a technological leap that opens the doors
to massive innovation that once this
happens,
once this happens in this,
and then all this stuff sort
of exponentially expands
in terms of technological
possibilities,
all you would need is a few hundred years
and you have an unrecognizable set of
technology.
Yeah,
sure.
You know what were talking about certain,
I mean,
you know,
anti matter idea that they're
still trying to figure out,
uh,
that's an insane sorts of energy
you have never even experienced.
Yeah.
You know,
with the,
with us grain of sand and you can
run a city and it was that big.
And then there's also the theory,
there's recent one,
that space time itself doesn't exist.
So the,
the speed of light barrier
becomes moot because that is,
I guess it's the holographic
quantum hologram there.
Quantum holographic
theory of the universe.
Sounds like Talbot's book.
Uh,
I can't remember holographic universe,
but it's,
yeah,
I think so.
But the idea that the universe is
basically just a geometry that,
that when you look at it from a certain
angle seems three dimensional and it
folds on,
it folds into itself.
So you could,
and it's traveled through
the wormhole thing.
It's not even that,
it's the idea that,
that,
that space time is an illusion is,
uh,
and that,
that it doesn't really exist.
And that's why,
uh,
you know,
like,
uh,
entanglement is possible.
You know,
the idea that,
you know,
spooky,
spooky action at a distance.
Yes.
That a quantum entanglement.
The reason that,
you know,
uh,
these,
you know,
Adam's on opposite ends of the universe
can be affect each other instantaneously
is cause they're not really at
an opposite ends of the universe.
They're really right next to each other.
It just seems like they're at
opposite ends of the universe.
Because our ability to
perceive as basically based
on what we have to do to stay
alive on this planet.
So our meager little chimp brains,
you have trying to,
trying to quantify all of these things
that are around us all the time.
So we put them into this sort of
three dimensional box of movement and,
and that the entire,
the entire universe could be a compact
thing that projects itself like a
hologram onto a screen.
I love these kinds of conversations
because I'm clearly too stupid to really
understand what I don't understand.
I don't listen anything I just said
and I don't understand you too.
So how stupid does that make me?
Well,
we don't understand each other.
We're all the same.
Yeah.
I think it'd be interesting to do it
like a documentary or something about,
uh,
about euphology.
Cause if one thing is the assumption
that they're extra terrestrial is an
assumption.
But the thing that intrigues me is
the power of ridicule to silence.
Even the most intelligent people in our
community from examining something like
the ridicule kept doctors
from accepting germs.
Sure.
Cause they didn't want to,
they didn't want to be
ridiculed by their peers.
And even now you've got people that will,
like Michael Shermer will cling to the
most absurd explanations for phenomena
like the f 16 a radar footage.
Uh,
what did he,
what was a Michael Shermer,
I can't even remember,
but it was,
it was pretty,
it really went to great lengths
that entailed having to basically,
uh,
diminish any respect you have for any of
the people who reported on the events.
It had to go and had to go into character
assassination in order to eliminate
it.
Yeah,
he loves the best way to kill an idea.
He's a professional skeptic and I like
Michael a lot and he's been on the
podcast may times,
but yeah,
I actually had him debate
Randall Carlson and,
um,
Graham Hancock about these ancient
civilizations and it wasn't very good for
him.
Like,
or some swanky moments.
Cause skeptics are believers.
Well the problem is they're leaving.
Even Scott,
the problem is being a skeptic itself,
it's a stupid way to look at the world.
You're actually sure about something.
I don't mean you shouldn't be objective.
No.
Be Skeptical.
Being skeptical is like,
ah,
I don't know.
But I know for sure that that's not true,
but it serves a massive purpose for
people that really don't understand things
and he can explain it to you.
And with actual science,
as long as the actual science
is being used and it's not,
character assassination is not mockery.
It's not,
it's not.
There's certain people
that are just debunkers.
They can call themselves skeptics,
but they're not looking at things like,
oh,
maybe that is effective.
Maybe that is healthy.
That is interesting and no,
they don't look at it that way.
They're looking at it,
they're trying to pick it apart and
that's fine if you can pick it apart,
but if you cannot,
you have to be objective
about the fact that,
oh well this is a very interesting
phenomenon and this is what we know about
science is that,
and this is what we know about this thing.
And right now we have,
we have a weird conundrum.
Did chariots of the gods,
did he work on Danica was,
he was he hundred percent
he's all is still in all in.
I asked him,
the first thing I asked him,
I said,
what is it the desperately
have to go pee go.
The first thing I asked him was
what is the most piece of evidence?
Does the,
you know,
and he pointed to this,
um,
a Mayan stone plaque that's in Pelinka.
I'm gonna have you ever seen it?
It's a,
it's this book.
It's a god,
a one of their,
um,
one of their former kings that
is lying on his back and he's,
it looks like he's moving some,
see Jamie,
see if we could find that thing.
It's this really cool,
uh,
carving that they found that looks like
there's a guy who is in a seat and it
looks like there's fire behind his back.
And you could say,
you could say that he's manipulating
controls on a ship and he's,
you know,
shooting a rocket into the heaven.
I would like to see what the s,
the mainstream version of
that is because it also,
it could just be art,
you know,
I'm imagining being,
yeah,
it could be that they,
they knew about certain things
being propelled by fire.
There it is.
Yep.
That's it.
So if you see this,
I mean,
that's a big ass stretch to say,
that guy's in a spaceship.
I don't know what the fuck that is.
He's sitting down can alter kind of.
He could.
Yeah,
but it doesn't look like
he's looking through an Ip.
Right.
What's true,
but what does that mean?
Is it a telescope?
Maybe he's just kind of telescope.
I mean they just an astronomer.
Yeah,
it is possible.
I don't think they had telescopes.
I don't think it telescope
was even invented till no.
Do they even have glass at that point?
Oh No.
Well I don't know if the Mayans did.
Wow.
But,
but that was his number one
piece of evidence was wow.
I was like,
that's kind of silly.
I mean when we were kids in the 70s the,
you know,
big foot,
and cherry to the gods
and everything was so new.
It look at this image,
look at the bottom of it.
Even the part where the flame supposed
to be coming out from below him.
Where's the flame?
The flame is the shit.
The very,
very bottom.
But I mean,
I'm not even sure I buy that.
If you were going to draw fire,
you do a really shitty job.
If that's your fire,
that doesn't really look like fire to me.
Like it could be anything.
Right?
Right.
If,
if that's fire,
like what is all the stuff around them?
What's all that stuff?
Is that that looked kind
of mechanical though,
right?
It looks like there's bolts does,
if they have a fire,
God maybe they drew the fire.
God,
it looks like a monkey
kind of face with titties.
Monkey's got some titties.
Oh,
now I get it.
Right.
And then the monkeys,
is that his teeth?
It's the first tutors arms actually.
Right?
It does.
It could be armed.
But that's the point is it's
so open to interpretation.
There's so much that you could
see if you're looking to see,
but what I do see is this guy who's,
he's reclining and chilling and it looks
like he's looking through something.
What's that thing hanging across him?
You see that thing across his arm.
You know what the fuck that is.
But here's the thing.
I don't think anybody knows
what the fuck that is.
But,
so for him to say that this was the
number one most compelling evidence,
I mean,
where people getting high at this point.
Oh,
so I'm in that could be just some
guy got high and LSD carve something.
Yeah,
they were,
um,
taking different kinds of
plants that have like search,
like acid in them.
There was a,
I had a great tour,
um,
in teaching Eatsa we,
uh,
went through and we hired a guide who
was a professor who was fantastic.
It was really good.
He was,
he was really loved Mayan civilization
is super passionate about it.
And then when he found out that I'd read
a bunch of books on and he was really
excited about it.
So he took us to these,
all these different areas.
But there was one area
where they had this like,
like hall where they
would just get fucked up.
And he was like,
this is,
this is where they would do their,
their psychedelics.
They would take different forms of plants.
There's a bunch of different
plants like a morning glory seeds.
Really?
Yeah.
Morning glory seeds.
The same ones you find today.
Yeah.
They actually try to mute them.
A lot of people don't know that morning
glory seeds actually contain what is the
active compound?
I think it's a cousin of LSD.
It's,
it's something psychoactive
that's very closely related.
And what you would do would
do is they would make it,
they would take the morning glory seeds.
They would,
they would soak them and I think they
would smash them and make a cake and bake
it.
So they have Lsa ls,
Lsa less surgical acid.
Right.
Is that lower surgery?
Casad concentrated.
Wow.
Yeah.
And uh,
so when you fly this,
they've engineered morning glory seeds.
Many of them to not be is psychoactive.
They've done things to them because a lot
of people in the 70s were getting high
off morning glory seeds.
Oh,
isn't that funny?
Yeah.
Terence Mckenna,
who's one of my favorite
psychedelic authors,
that was his first psychedelic
trip who was a young band.
He ate morning glory seeds.
He bought them and smashed them up.
Teens trying to get high sick
and after eating flowers,
seeds
today show what years that,
that's so funny.
Oh yeah.
They bought flowers.
Seeds recently.
They've probably heard me talk about it.
Oh,
that's baby rose.
That's a funny morning.
Glory.
Yeah.
Okay.
Those are morning glory ones.
Um,
yeah,
but see,
smoking banana peels,
I don't know why they're getting sick.
They're probably pussies.
Too many little bitches.
Uh,
apparently these seeds contain
[inaudible] surgical acid,
[inaudible] LSA,
which closely resembles LSD.
But see all of them don't have that.
No one.
They say they got sick with vomiting.
Oh,
they had a bad trip.
And introspection.
Introspection is sickening.
Yeah,
that's the worst part.
But yeah,
apparently that's how a lot of the Mayans,
a lot of the Mayans used to take Lsa.
They used to take this stuff.
They used to take morning glory seeds
and Mckenna said that when he did it,
he saw a lot of uh,
uh,
like classic Mayan iconography.
He saw like a lot of imagery till maybe
that's just how it reacts with the
brain.
It could a,
there's sauce.
There's,
that's a really plausible theory.
There's another theory that's a little
more slippery and this one is a very woo
woo.
And the idea is that every
experience that you have,
like say if you take mushrooms,
right,
every,
when you're eating mushrooms,
you're not just having an experience
where your brain is interacting with the
substance,
but you are in fact experiencing all
of the people that have ever interacted
with this trip.
So that,
that's one of the reasons why silicide
been is so potentially potent,
is that you're not just accessing,
we're talking about morning glory seeds.
Oh,
right.
And other people getting high on morning
glory seeds and this was something that
the Mayans did.
We,
I remember we did that
when I was in high school.
Wow.
There you go.
Um,
but their exit lanes lot the thought will,
the Mckenna was saying
that when he did it,
he saw all this,
uh,
I think he said either mine or a gypsum
iconography saw a lot of like images
that were very similar to like
these ancient civilizations.
And the thought is that either this is
what's it's doing to your brain or the
more woo woo thought is that when you
are having a psychedelic experience,
especially when you're consuming
something like a fungus,
like a psilocybin,
that you're not just having
this experience where
this chemicals interacting
with your brain,
but you're entering into the realm of
all the previous experiences that human
beings have had with this,
which is one of the reasons why
silicide and has such a rich history.
Uh,
and,
uh,
these are incredibly potent experiences
when you do take psilocybin.
And then also Iowasca I lost when you
take that people see Jaguars and snakes
and all these different things.
And so the thought behind that is
that you are interacting with all the
experiences that all these different
people have had with these,
with these various substances.
Is it,
what's genetic inside you?
Like,
I mean,
who knows?
it's all just stored.
Yeah.
That's all just speculating.
But that what's interesting
is that Mckenna said that,
um,
ketamine,
which at the time when he was alive,
he died in the early,
I think early two thousands.
Right?
I think he died like early two thousands,
um,
that ketamine was a weird drug to take
cause it seemed like no one had taken it
yet that you would take it and it's like
you were in an empty office building.
Like it's all built but
there's no one in the building.
Whereas if you're taking LSD
or if you're taking psilocybin,
you've this,
all these experiences that people had.
So it's like the drug itself or the
compound itself absorbs the experiences of
the user and transfers
them to the next users.
Very,
we will buy this.
I like that idea though.
Yeah.
You do something that's as
potent is like silicide and you,
you're open a fucking anything.
Like if that's possible,
if you can eat five grams of mushrooms
and that happens like Goddamn it,
I'll,
I'll take whatever you got.
What else you got?
What else do you tell me?
I don't know what the fuck this is.
Like what is this and that's,
yeah.
I don't know.
You,
you talked about psilocybin can
treat intractable depression.
Yes.
People take,
it opens up doors in your brain,
then you take it.
One will always stay close silicide trip.
And then for like six months,
their depression is completely gone.
And My,
my parents had a,
had a friend who was a
experimented on in Canada as a,
uh,
with the LSD.
So she lost her mind eventually.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
she didn't know at the
time he was in government.
They,
the CIA was experimenting on Canada,
on Canadians of course.
And she was wanting to get across
that clearcut doleful Muslin.
Yeah,
that's right.
Back then it was harder there.
There was a same rob.
Yeah.
They couldn't get over it.
That's his thing.
They had,
they had the full cooperation of the,
it was the defund Baker I think.
Yup.
He does know that Ted's kids,
NC swore the Unabomber.
Uh,
I know about the beauty bumper part.
He was a part of the lst Harvard
Studies Alessi he was in,
so this is kind of the same,
uh,
same deal.
Yeah.
They cooked that guy's brain.
Yup.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a documentary about it.
It's really interesting.
He was like a 16 year old kid when he
first went to Harvard because he was so
fucking smart that uh,
he,
it was entering to Harvard
at 16 years of age and um,
there was a psychologist that,
uh,
was working at Harvard
at the time that he is,
he's been photograph with and was
friends with and he was a part of this
program.
This guy was notoriously ruthless with
his application of Lsd to young people.
I mean,
he just gave it a shot.
Let's see what it does,
fries them forever.
But here's the thing,
and I've been thinking
about this a lot lately.
I think that he was on to something,
and this is what he was
on to what he was onto.
He was trying to kill people that were
creating technology because he felt like
technology is going to
be the end of humans.
He's right.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Definitely as fuck on acid.
Then probably gave him a fucking
coffee cup full of acid at 16.
Yeah.
I mean who knows how much they were.
They didn't know what the doses were.
They were just experimenting with people.
Cause I,
Ken Keyes leary role part of that.
Exactly.
Yeah.
A few weeks ago,
and I read an article online
and at the bottom it said,
this article has been written by a,
a program,
not by human.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I was like,
what?
Yeah.
I arts paint,
paintings,
paintings done by Ai.
Like a symphony.
No,
he lives in Bombay on what's happening.
It's,
it's coming in it now.
Once they figure out a way to make a
reality that's indiscernible from the
reality that we're currently experiencing,
which is just,
it's around the corner.
Yeah.
That's only like,
or happened 2 billion years ago
and we're just living in it.
Only know what's in front of you.
And you know what I mean?
Sure.
Well,
yeah,
and if you've done the,
you know,
the,
what is it,
the oculus stuff and all that.
I mean we have a HTC vive
and the back and see hazing.
Right?
Yeah.
It's amazing.
But your emotions,
everything,
it's like you're there.
It's no different.
Yeah.
It's very similar.
There's one where you jump off a building.
Have you ever tried that one?
No.
You go out in the diving board
and a on a high rise and step off.
Yeah,
well they are.
They're using it to treat PTSD
and
it's going to happen yet.
Once they figure out a way to give you
some experiences that you can't tell
whether or not those
experiences or were real or not,
then the aliens or feel they'll,
they'll land and they'll interact.
It is really is the matrix,
but I think that artificial life and art
and an intelligence that is sentient,
that is also completely autonomous,
that can run itself and decide for itself.
It's only a matter of time.
It's not a matter of,
this is not like hg wells
science fiction 200 years ago.
Like we're just guessing.
This is like you could see it coming.
Yeah.
They already have machine learning.
They already have certain artificial
intelligence that guesses certain things
about you and,
but Siri is still a dumb cunt.
What's better?
Big Spear.
Siri tried Bixby.
Is Samsung's version of Siri yet?
Like A,
I don't know.
That's all.
Never use it.
I have a sense on the phone.
I don't know.
It's incredibly effective yet,
but it has a terrible voice.
Kept that button to map
it out to anything else.
Is it the voice of Bill Beck speak?
Cause that'd be really cool.
All right.
From the Hawk or courtship
of Eddie's father
tell you about this fan is it can pick,
get you.
I'd never
utility and did the end forgot about that.
Yeah.
And he had that hot Japanese
lady that was his housekeeper,
but he never,
uh,
hooked up with her.
I was like,
come on.
She's right there bro.
She seems real nice.
True.
She seems lonely too.
Seeing what's right in front of you.
Didn't get it.
I'm like,
how will you not with her man?
She's so nice to your kid.
You guys are biggest sweet family.
Very Long.
You know,
maybe if he'd gotten like
five or six more seasons,
whoever is on Netflix or something.
Yeah,
it would have pushed that angle.
Yeah.
I started watching a
magician a little bit.
You've seen that?
What does that speak show?
Oh God.
What is it?
One of the worst of all,
it was one of the CBS movie mysteries.
It was like with Colombo and
was terrible on every level.
Yeah.
He was the magician.
He was his magic to solve crimes
would know what the Magic,
oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
How do you solve crimes with magic?
You don't do magic.
Yeah.
Oh,
and you pretend you're solving crimes
and then someone else solves a crime.
Yeah.
It was probably a producer's idea.
Right.
It's,
hey,
I got to like match guys.
Here's the show.
I'm a magician who solves crime.
Sell it.
I've got another meeting,
I've got to go and he leaves.
I got to show it.
Yeah.
I had a pit crews.
They gave me a pitch once.
Uh,
it was a guy who was immortal.
He was an Egyptian.
This was a pitch to me.
It was going to play this
guy who was a mortal far.
It's good casting.
Yeah.
Mortal.
He got,
yeah.
Happened back then.
And a woman put a curse on me because I
was like banging her sister or something
like that.
And uh,
the curse was that you would live forever.
So here I was,
many thousands of years later,
I had to pretend that I was a
regular person and I could never die.
And that was the Sitcom.
It was calm.
Yeah,
it was a sitcom.
It was the dumbest idea
I've ever heard in my life.
Great.
As a one hour to solve crimes,
because I know,
I knew it was going to be a problem
when I met the guy and he was wearing
bowling shoes,
but he wasn't going bowling.
That means ask those fuckers
shoes.
My shoes are interesting.
Wait a second.
I used to do that.
Well,
do you remember when there
was the writer teams,
but it was always the one guy who was
the typer and the other guy was really
funny.
Yeah.
There was a lot of those teams and those
teams would branch off and one of those
guys would get a lot
of money and then the,
you know,
they were the time you got the wrong guy,
paid the fucking,
oh,
we paid the typer.
There was a lot of that with the teams.
The teams always seem to
be like one really talented
person who's kind of may be
introspective and weird.
And I eventually figured out,
oh,
I can just hire a typist
and he got rid of that guy.
But then that guy got
a big development deal.
Remember development deals.
Oh my God,
I had so many of them.
I had one one year where they gave me
a shit ton of money and we never did
anything.
All the money I had three months,
I had about four right after news radio.
Did you?
Yeah.
And they create smaller and
smaller networks each time.
Yeah.
Right.
You get down to the CW,
you know you've got an issue.
I might have to actually write something.
No,
no cooking channel.
So what is this obsessing?
What is your,
your more recent obsessing about Ufo was,
what's the origin of this?
Part of it is just the fact
that that the evidence,
just the evidence itself says you have
to take this seriously and yet no one
does a or very,
very few people do.
And even like the,
again that [inaudible] 16 footage that
even Neil degrasse Tyson who is a great
skeptic said,
uh,
on one of the late nights actually,
he said,
well,
if you really want to look
at the possibility of some,
a non human intelligence,
that f 16 stuff is pretty compelling.
What is the episode STD stuff?
That's the stuff that,
uh,
to the stars academy put out.
It was the CIA Tom Delonge.
He's crazy,
but I had never met on the podcast.
Yeah,
very nice guy.
What do you see?
And he said she's a very nice guy and
a brilliant musician and he's a loon.
Yeah.
I've never met a fucking full on believer.
I mean he left blink one 82 to
go do this to the stars academy.
Shit,
he said the biggest Goddamn
rock band on the planet.
Okay.
Here's something interesting about
this and this was pointed out like by,
um,
okay.
A film video film by fighter jet shows
an unknown object near San Diego video
from 2004 was released by
the US Department of Defense.
Um,
while the way it moves,
there's something about the
way it moves is really weird.
Huh?
Can't yet though.
One of the pilots told the you immediate
the object was not from this world.
Hmm.
Yeah.
And here's the thing.
It's like the skeptics,
in order to dismiss it,
they have to go well event.
They have to make arguments like that.
Jet Fighters are not better
observers than anyone else.
Pull up Mick wards take on that mic ward,
the guy who he runs deep,
um,
uh,
what does it met?
A bunk metabolic can runs a debunking
site and he's another one of those guys
that is all in with the,
the conventional explanation goes way
out of his way to not look at anything
that could be blockers.
Yes,
yes.
Comes Razor says,
you know that if you have to go to
great lengths to dismiss something,
right,
that's not falling.
Ockham's razor Ockham's razor says
if the jet pilot says he saw this,
he saw it.
I think he had an interesting
take on it though.
And one of the things is there's a time
during the video where the pilot shifted
from one x to two x,
which makes the image
move more because you're,
you have magnification.
Like have you ever used magnifying
glasses by knows like if you use a 15 x by
knows it's very difficult
to hold in the state yet,
but six,
six,
you can kind of look at
things in the distance.
Yeah.
But that's,
if you don't have about,
uh,
about $3 million worth of stabilization
equipment on your jet walked on to this
object.
Right.
Which is why that stays in Loc.
He had an explanation though
that was kind of interesting.
And when it breaks free of the lock
and how does that got unbelievable.
Just take off or something like that.
It just,
at one point just the,
you just breaks free the lock
and that's almost impossible.
I have a glide sound possible for
anything that manage bills to do what?
The quality of cameras today.
Why is this footage so shitty?
Uh,
that this is infrared footage footage?
Yeah.
I mean,
do you need this?
When you're shooting at things in the sky,
you can't rely on [inaudible].
When you're looking at heat,
you can't hate sickness visually.
It's so far.
It would be the rabbit hole.
How to debunk conspiracy theories
using fact logic and research.
So what is he saying?
What is he saying?
The Program da Da.
Make that a little larger
for my stupid dies.
He said a for all.
We made sure you are talking
about the right video.
There's two that are confused here.
We're talking about the gimbal video,
which is not from the Nimitz incident.
Just discussed here.
So scroll down a little bit.
Uh,
the gimbal video is an okay.
Yeah,
that's the one we're looking at.
It's an unknown date and location
from an up from unknown pilots.
Nope.
The tick tock one are young pilots.
Yeah,
that's 2004.
Okay.
That's David forever.
The media is discussed.
These videos,
Tom Delonge to the stars.
The link contains the frames.
What's he saying?
Keep going.
Uh,
the black shape or on the object.
Some kind of infrared flare glare.
We know that the shape of a
very bright infrared source,
like the engine of a plane can be
much bigger than the object itself is
explained here.
Okay,
so this is like a flare that
that'll explain the move.
Yeah,
it doesn't explain again.
Ockham's razor is,
okay,
so this guy does,
this guy is saying it
looks nothing like it.
Well,
even if it is a jet,
a chats not capable of
breaking free from the lock,
right.
To lock onto it.
And if you look at that,
you can see the jet,
his own example.
Debunks is debunking.
Need not be moving.
Yeah.
The video need not be moving.
The assumption that this guy doing
probably a few hours research has come up
with something that is more credible than
a trained fighter pilot who was there
and visually seeing it.
What do you think it and
tracking if you had to guess.
I don't know.
Let's get crazy.
I think it is.
It is another,
it is an intelligent craft is a
craft being piloted intelligently.
Why aren't they talking to us?
We're fucking apes.
Mileage.
Yeah.
Like go in and talk to us.
We're assholes.
When you look at it,
I forgot.
You're right.
Leaving fucking plastic straws everywhere.
Oh,
we cured it.
No more plastic straws.
When you're a kid looking
at a an ant colony,
you didn't go listen to me aunts.
Yes.
You just looked at them.
You know there was,
and they said,
why?
Why don't they go to the White House it?
We said,
well why would you,
when you look at an ant colony go,
I must speak to the queen.
Yes.
No,
I've always said he was looking at ants.
Yeah.
That's what the most
ridiculous thing about like
the old movies,
like the old movies,
it would land on the White House lawn.
Right.
That's still today.
That's it.
Yeah.
Burrata nickname,
whatever that thing was.
Yeah.
Two burrata.
I'd like to talk nick too.
Yeah,
that's the day.
The are still like you said,
1940 or 50 50 50 50 fucking great.
Great movie.
I watched it really reasonably
cause it's a little bit right.
Stories are great.
He was a Christ pair.
Well his name is John Carpenter.
Oh,
I see.
Christ was a carpenter.
Shoot.
That object out of his hand.
The first second he pulls it out.
Do remember he has that thing
that's going to cure cancer.
They shoot him,
they shoot him,
shoot it out of his hand and meeting him.
And then at the end of the movie he is a,
he is killed and resurrected.
That's right.
Right.
Yeah.
They shoot him taking the
robot takes them the robot.
That robot robot.
Yeah.
Very tall.
And like he looked like you would
want a robot to look in 1950.
Yes.
Yeah.
All metal and shits smooth chrome.
Those,
those were the days we thought that they
would communicate like it wasn't there
a whole rash of them that
were seen over Washington DC.
Yeah,
there was a peer,
he has,
it was dozens,
dozens of Ufos tracked and admitted by
the government that they tracking them
and watching them.
But they,
uh,
essentially,
and then at the end of
their explanation was,
yeah.
Nothing,
nothing particularly important.
You know,
we have a mutual friend who claims,
I won't say her name
but she can now cause I,
I wrote her off as a lunatic
when I first started it.
Yeah.
Well she was claiming to
be adopted and then I,
I was doing a show with her years ago
and she just telling us the story.
We're all like a,
Huh,
that's pretty funny.
And she says,
and then they took a scoop out
of my back and I'm like a scoop.
They took a scoop out of your back
and she showed on her back shoulder.
There was a hexagon,
old diamond shaped scoop out of her back.
Uh,
a divot that hexagon.
Yeah.
That was clearly,
clearly and no scar tissue.
Maybe she's a crazy bitch.
No scar tissue man know
how to make this story.
Yeah,
give myself a little punch,
but I have a hole punch back there.
Worked at a bookstore at the time years
ago when I went into the alien section
was the world's biggest
bookstore in Toronto.
It was the name of it.
And of course I went to the alien
section and just look all this crap up
immediately.
And there are other people with the scope.
Well there's a lot of other people
with stories and some of them have like
little pieces of something in their body.
I remember you talking
to me about this many,
many years ago.
I was like,
oh well Dave's interested.
It was like implants.
You're talking about people that
have alien implants in their body.
And that's the things I,
to me it's just,
I guess the thing that I'm kind of
obsessed with now is just the cause we're
comedians.
Yes.
And the power of ridicule,
uh,
to silence,
debate is unbelievably potent.
Sure.
And we're part of that.
We're part of the machinery
that was used very,
very consciously by the
government to silence any inquiry.
You know,
it was like,
you know,
feeding it,
feeding the story the right way to late
night talk show hosts made it so that
nobody would talk about it.
So do you think that the government
consciously fed those ideas to like Johnny
Carson and those folks?
There's documentation of a,
of a pro,
you know,
of that they,
to,
uh,
to make the UFO phenomena ridiculous.
Do you think they did that
to avoid mass hysteria?
Like if you're the
government and you know,
there's nothing out there but you
see these people freaking out,
you go,
okay,
look,
we've looked,
we've used all of our military might,
all of our scientific power
and we don't see shit,
I'm not buying this,
but these people are freaking out.
This has the real potential to get
out of hand and go sideways on us.
Let's just start making fun of this.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Cause uh,
I think it's more likely that there's
something there that they feel powerless
to control.
Do you think Kennedy was taken down into
the basement of whatever and shown the
alien sitting there is what I say
about aliens with in regards to Trump.
If this,
anybody that would
fucking tell us it's him,
I'll tweet it,
tweet it,
immediately,
tweet it.
[inaudible] are real.
But CNN is fake.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's still,
he is the failing New York
Times sales defined Ufo
at area 51 if the government does have
the evidence they are never going to show
it to Trump.
That's the problem.
Like what the fuck's the point being
president if you can't find it,
if I knew that to become president
meant you get all the access to Ufos,
I might go.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's all very good.
I'm going to try for that.
The presidents who have
tried haven't gotten there.
No,
no one gets it.
Like Jimmy Carter.
Jimmy Carter said he was,
he he's,
he had a Ufo experience.
Yeah.
He saw something.
He said he saw something but see that
was back in the 70s where everybody was
seeing shit.
They were all talking about things.
It was part of the zeitgeists people
were legit like after close encounters of
the third kind,
especially people who are legitimately
thinking that aliens were going to come.
Yeah.
He proposed such a possible
scenario and that movie was so good.
It wasn't anything you
expected it was going to be.
But like here I was going to say,
here's like another example is like the
Rendlesham like that explanation of the
sixteens locked,
you know,
footage,
uh,
like Rendlesham forest where the,
they claimed that these
American soldiers in the woods,
out in England,
uh,
mistook the light,
a light house light for a spacecraft
that they were within 20 feet of a craft
that they saw and took notes
on different lines of yeah.
They walk,
not even like right up against it.
And they wrote down notes,
saw like different sort of hieroglyphs
on the ship itself described it's
described the,
the feel of it,
this electrostatic feel
of being around it.
And the official
explanation was they missed,
took a lighthouse several
miles away for this spacecraft.
So outcomes razor against us.
That's hard to believe that these trained
observers and that's the other thing.
They always tried to dismiss the idea
that trained observers are better
observers.
Um,
but they are better observers.
Sure.
In the age of,
yeah.
Today where everyone has a high
definition camera in their pocket.
Have you taken,
have you taken a photograph
of the moon on your,
on your phones?
It doesn't look like the moon.
What's true,
right.
There's no details.
It comes out of the lung.
The lenses are too wide,
but,
but I'll comes.
Razors has all right,
they saw something but they,
you know,
cause what is the likelihood that trained
observers who have been on this base
for years on this night would mistake a
lighthouse that they've seen every night
for the entire time they've
been on this base for a Ufo?
I mean,
what is the likelihood that
that explanation is correct?
I'm not aware of that store.
Oh,
Rendlesham forest.
Yeah.
How'd he say it?
Bent Woods or incurring
some Rendlesham and r.
Rendlesham forest was bandwidths.
It was two nights to get
character actor on Colombo.
Where are you up?
Where and
it was a,
and it's a nuclear installations.
Rendlesham forest and nuclear
installations are always
ripe with Ufo stories.
Yeah.
What year was this?
Uh,
this was in the 80s.
80?
Yeah.
Mm.
Interesting.
And it's,
you know,
and it said,
obviously the obvious explanation
is not the explanation.
The only thing you can accept is
that these observers saw something.
You described it accurately.
Is it something that had crashed,
if you want to say that?
No,
it came down was,
was,
uh,
landed in the forest and,
and took off.
What do you think of the rotten
king case the night before that?
Roswell.
I,
I think it's probably true.
Real.
You're all in?
Yeah.
Well,
David,
I mean,
because the interesting,
but again,
because the,
because the cover stories for our,
so much less believable then an alien.
Yeah.
I used to have a joke about it.
They put it on the paper that they have
recovered a crashed Ufo and alien bodies
and the next day set up,
we made a mistake.
It was just a balloon.
What about,
what about the aliens?
They're Mexicans.
They were drinking,
apparently they thought the balloons up,
Yada.
He got a little crazy.
We just invented some new stuff.
Yeah.
Out of nowhere.
And then 30 years later they go,
oh,
we were,
they were high altitude a
dummies that we were dropping.
That's right.
To test how they would fall.
And that was,
we have lasers and visibility cloaks.
Well the,
they showed up again the next day
with a bunch of weather balloons.
Scraps.
Yeah.
Like look,
this is,
yeah.
What the guy holding it up.
Like what they don't tell you is that
they flew the wreckage out to Wright
Patterson air force in two separate
planes and the Truman met them there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So I mean,
yeah,
the more rational separate planes the
morning because they were worried that one
would crash the weather,
the weather balloon thing is not as
rational as something weird happened.
I listened to,
I want it to be alien so
bad I questioned myself.
So that's my problem.
I want to do that stuff.
But again,
I,
I won't like,
I'll be skeptical about stuff that just
seems crazy or people that you know,
you know,
sort of ascribe some sort of
metaphysical explanation for all this.
Uh,
my,
my thing is just,
well if the preponderance of the evidence
says something happened but doesn't
tell you what happened,
then you still have to
believe something happened.
Not knowing what happened isn't evidence
that it didn't happen and yet you're
still a flat earthers yeah.
Have you looked outside?
It's seems flat.
Yeah.
Have you studied Hashtag
faith spaces fake?
Uh,
no.
Just lived into people dumber.
There's people that are so dumb.
You think the earth is
flat and this people that,
that are so dumb,
they make fun of the people
that are dumber than them.
Yeah.
They think that that
space is fake spaces fake.
There's no space,
no space.
And it's basically,
well that's the holographic theory.
Yeah.
When you Google it,
it's really religious.
It's a,
it's all about the
firmament and the Bible.
That makes sense.
They're really,
it's very strange because the stars
are hung in the sky over earth.
What you would call like,
yeah.
Sand,
youtube people.
Here it is.
And you know what?
Fuck don't have full again cause I'm 56.
Wow.
That's incredible.
Human explore.
Ocean Ocean title.
I understand.
I have to be some times.
Um,
yeah.
Hashtag spaces faith,
human dug earth.
Mm.
Yeah.
Human explore ocean suddenly beginning
to discover a thousand miles really well
written,
super,
super compelling.
They can discover a thousand miles.
I wonder how many of those I was
talking to you about Rene de Resta,
who's the woman who studies
all these Russian troll farms.
So then they're mocked.
I wonder how much of that is
them that the Russians side,
flat earth,
uh,
spaces fake department where they just
mock it cause it's always in English.
I don't think there's a lot of flat earth,
Russian proponents.
God,
if I was one of those Russian guys that
I would want that to be my department.
Yeah.
Just cold call people.
Globe tards or globe heads.
Yeah.
If you believe in,
if you're around.
Yeah.
I've saved some of these memes
because they're so wonderful.
They're just like,
this is just rich.
I had the worst duper
ride with a guy who was,
uh,
a flat earth there.
Yeah,
he was.
And he was a computer programmer.
What?
Yeah,
a computer programmer slash
flat Arthur and driving an Uber.
Not Working at NASA the
whole time while he,
while he drove me crazy,
he drove me.
He knew what he was doing it.
I think it's doing it on purpose.
Yeah,
I think so.
How did he start it off?
So I bet you're one of those guys
that believes the Earth's round,
Huh?
Well,
I talked about the beautiful
view from the plane.
They picked me up at the airport.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
it's so beautiful.
The sunset over the
curvature of the earth.
That's how it started.
I think of us went up.
Not really the curvature of the earth.
That's how it started.
And he will not stop.
Oh,
my point where I was,
I think,
I think I tore my clothes off.
He made me sell insane.
There's so many of them now and you know,
we,
we've uncovered the origins of it
are what we think the origins of it.
It was a troll from four Chan,
four Chan was fucking around and they
started promoting this idea that the earth
is actually the flower.
It started that a lot of
things start from that sense.
That's where the free bleeding
movement started from.
I don't know what that is.
Women are expressing their power by not
controlling their menstrual cycle with
pads or tampons.
Just bleeding into their
pants to show their power.
Yeah.
They did it on four Chan as a joke,
and the women started
doing it in real life.
For Real.
Yeah.
They thought that thought it was like,
this is a way to like,
these people were disgusted
by menstrual blood.
Yeah.
Shit on the Patriarchy by
showing your pussy blood.
God.
Crazy.
It makes me want to start one four.
Chan is the best.
They just,
they're so good at that.
They're so good at starting these goofy
ass fucking little movements and then
getting people behind it.
It's like a,
it's like a game.
Yeah.
A game.
Well,
it's,
you know what it is?
It's probably a bunch
of really smart people.
Um,
some of them not so smart,
but some of them really smart that are
stuck at their desks and they're bored as
shit with some computer job
somewhere and they think of,
in the meantime,
they just decided to fuck with people.
Right.
We're talking about a flat
earthers free bleeding,
the free bleeding movement,
which was also started by four Chan Four
Chan started this movement where women
would express their power by not
controlling their menstrual cycle by just
letting the blood leak
out into their pants.
And they did it as a joke that four Chan
did and women started actually doing
it.
Caught on.
Yeah.
That's a lot of these things.
It's so hard to mock,
but it's so,
so hard to figure out like what
is mockery and what's real.
Exactly.
What is parody and what's,
what's,
what's the onion?
The onion is,
you know,
have you,
do you know that James Lindsey,
Peter Boghossian was how the woman's name,
the one one that we didn't meet
the grievance studies hoaxes.
Do you know
Peter but goes in as a professor
at University of Portland and um,
I think that's the
school he's in Portland.
Um,
and he decided to,
with these other academics,
publish these fake papers on like,
um,
uh,
rape and dog parks and like,
like,
uh,
cis normative,
like different,
like [inaudible] what happened?
No people loved them.
Ridiculous things like fat bodybuilding,
like bodybuilding contest,
a contest for fat.
People like to talk about the impairment
with the importance of these things,
like things that you would read and you
would think would be obviously a parody.
Someone's fucking around.
They submit these,
these academic journals
not only get published,
but they get praised for,
for their scholarship,
and then they came out and said,
hey,
we were fucking with you guys.
This is all Joe.
Yeah.
It's out there and you know,
you guys love these papers,
you morons,
and that this is problem.
Part of the problem with the humanities
today is that things are so sideways in
terms of like,
it's so difficult to find out what's,
what's parody and what's reality.
Yeah.
It's insane.
It's an insane time is insane as it gets.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Then it gets,
it says very unsettling.
It's fine to not know if
someone's having me on or not.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well,
it's very,
all the structures that used that for
good or for bad would filter things down
are gone.
Yeah.
You know,
like we,
you know,
everything was handed over to powerful
people who filtered what we were given to
know.
There used to be,
uh,
an agreement of common sense
that used to hang around.
I think the cure is fine reading and I
think we're going to accept that cure
because I,
you know,
Ilan is working on some
sort of neural link things.
The only way we'll know if
someone's telling them the truth.
I think it's good.
We're going to accept it and we're
going to give in and we're gonna we're,
we're going to be able to,
I'll take it another step further.
I think they're going to
create a universal language.
I've been thinking about this a lot.
I think there's going to be a universal
language that probably is a augmented
reality,
some augmented reality language shapes
or some kind of symbolism that is
something that we agreed to and we're
probably not going to accept it because
we're old.
We're like,
fuck this next generation.
Our kids,
maybe even our kids,
kids are kids.
Kids are going to be the first people
to adopt it and then it's going to be
universal worldwide and with augmented
reality and some sort of ability to
interact with each other
through kind of bandwidth.
I remember the first time I heard about
cochlear implants as the first thing
that popped in my head is,
this is the start.
Yeah.
This is the interface now officially a,
you're a sidebar.
Cochlear implant.
You are a Cyborg.
Oh,
he's a $600 one.
People with apple watches on,
yeah.
You're wearing an apple watch.
Like what do you,
what do you,
what is that?
You have a computer that's constantly
strapped to you all the time,
is you monitoring your heart rate,
you know,
and then we've been sitting here and,
uh,
when we don't know something,
accessing the entire
store of human knowledge,
Jamie's our sidebar,
we're accessing all of human
knowledge in an instant.
True.
Anytime we will not.
That was Elan's other thing
that he said on the podcast.
You're already a Cyborg.
You have a phone.
It just,
it's not in your body,
but it's something you're holding onto.
Yeah.
It's calming.
It's voluntary cyborg.
Did you guys read the
third wave years ago?
Was that a book here?
I forgot it now know that was
the protection of all this.
Yeah,
and the early eighties and it was a
prediction and the one thing a third way
predicted was that the next generation,
the first line in it,
I remember it was at,
it's all about information.
Yeah.
It's all going to be
about sharing information.
You know that someone's going to
figure out a way to share information.
Well,
that's when I saw the cochlear implant.
I thought,
well,
if you're all right,
so your,
your brain is interpreting an electronic
signal as information directly.
It's bypassing the ear entirely.
Right,
and it's just a neuronal
connection and does that will,
that eventually is how we
will access the Internet,
will access the Internet as
though it is our own thoughts.
It will be as easily as
I remember your name.
I don't remember any other fact that is
on record the matrix and we'll all be
part of the same.
Yeah,
exactly.
We won't be sitting in pods somewhere.
Well,
I think it speak for yourself and
initially will be like a peripheral thing.
You'd be able to tap into it
or not as you as you wish,
but I think as time goes on,
it's going to be more and more integrated.
Just like distinguished
it from your own mind.
Like you used to have to go to a computer
that was hardwired into the wall and
you'd have to dial up to get online.
Yeah.
Now everything's instantaneous.
This in your phone,
and this isn't me.
I remember when we were on news radio,
I first got an apple computer and got
online and I was fucking fascinated.
I couldn't believe,
and the two comp you serve,
this is how we got to bring it all around.
The first thing I did
was download reports,
downloading Ufo,
like a Dork,
like learning all these things.
Yeah.
Well I remember the first chat with
somebody I remember in 1993 and it was 95
office computer.
First Time I had an Newsradio was the
first time I had an email account.
I remember that.
And getting on online.
I know and I mean,
yeah,
at first I think I went
to the Lubes site sure.
To see what was on there and you know,
watch Hieronymus Bosch painting
download in about 30 minutes
and then that was,
I was going,
oh my God,
it's like I'm at the Lou.
Why remember you had a
program on your laptop,
this was like 96 you had a program
on your laptop that kept crashing,
but when it worked it was amazing
because we give you the news as a screen
saver,
as a screen saver.
The news would just come up constantly
in a constant flow of news edge with
technologies and I wish
that still existed.
It doesn't exist anymore.
I don't even think it was Wifi.
I think you owe me again my head,
an ISD n line in my house,
I remember which gave me 128 kilobits per
second years ahead of everybody I knew
I had a t one line installed in my house.
I remember it like it
was like I need those.
The only,
I lived in the woods.
It was the only way I could
get like really high speed
Internet access had carve
a fucking hole in the ground
and give me a business pipe.
Amazing.
Now five g's around the corner,
man,
five t's facet.
If they say it's going to be hundreds
of times faster than everything.
Again,
it's,
yeah,
it's like to a,
to a fiber optic link.
Yeah.
On your phone.
I think cds or those are gone now
forever not saved just in case.
Just to shit.
Well,
the real question is like where are we
storing all this stuff if we're only
storing it in one zero was like we were
talking about the demise of civilization
and they pass that up.
Right.
But that's what,
that's what probably,
I mean,
every society probably,
I don't think they reached
that 10,000 years ago,
but I think every society probably reaches
some point where everything is just
ones and Zeros on a database somewhere,
but,
and then it crashes.
It's a physical place,
right?
Where this stuff exists.
Oh,
something,
all our email accounts
exists somewhere was huge.
Children's with Internet exchanges.
Sure.
No,
no,
that's absolutely the case.
But also if something happens
in the grid goes down and we,
I mean we're hit right?
If a manatee yeah,
for sure of what what Dr Robert
Schoch was talking about.
If there's a fucking lightning storm that
he really torches buildings and starts
everything on fire,
good luck accessing all that shit.
Not only that,
if human beings just skip a generation,
like we have a generation
of turmoil and chaos and,
and then we slowly rebuild civilization.
How many of those people are
gonna Understand Computer Code?
How many of these people
are gonna Understand Linux?
How many of these people that are coming
up without any education from a formal
university,
no Internet connection
whatsoever for perhaps
hundreds of years.
It's like the resetting of
civilization you talked about earlier.
Exactly.
Start all over again.
And that's when the aliens come.
Cause they know we can't do anything.
Withdraw Shit on cloud tap type.
Yeah.
They wait until we can't take pictures
anymore and then they come back and
reengineer.
Yeah.
Right now they're just relying on the
fact that nobody can frame a shot.
Well,
the weirdest thing about the alien
theory was that they came down and
genetically manipulated lower hominids.
That's the species.
That's the weirder ones.
Or that they are,
they are,
uh,
later evolved version of us
coming back to check on us.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
And that's the other thing too,
is about that archetypal image
of the alien with the gray hair.
And the big black eyes is that if you go,
you go down from Australia,
pithy kiss to home modern homosapien.
If you make this connect,
you see this hunched over,
very hairy,
almost champ,
like humanoid and then standing up.
But,
but losing all of his hair and the head
is much larger doubling of the human
brain size over a period
of 2 million years.
Well,
where's that going?
Is that going to keep going?
Well,
if it keeps going,
this is what you're going to get.
You're gonna get a fee feeble
thing with a giant head.
And that's what these aliens are.
They're always feeble with giant heads.
It's true.
Yeah.
Terrible.
Uh,
and if they left,
left,
they've been living off
earth for a long time.
Yeah.
Then,
yeah,
you're buddies.
You know,
they're very out of shape.
Well,
they also have no penises or Vaginas,
so they realize that saves a lot of times.
That gives you time to get stuff done.
I'm,
I'm already there and it's
more of a meritocracy.
You're not banging people
based on their tits and ass.
You don't have that anymore.
There's no more that you
just more wasted time.
Yeah.
Just sharing your thoughts
transparently through the air.
No worries.
You don't need an orb like
in the woody Allen movie.
Don't even need to pick things up anymore.
Everything's telekinetic.
Right.
Using that giant head to move shit around.
Never have to leave your
house like your pod.
There's a guy that
worked supposedly a pan.
I don't know if you really
worked at area 51 but the,
the,
the whole story was our,
sorry,
are good document or is it,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's just one of those,
it can't,
we,
it's just dealing with him
as an individual to go,
okay,
this guy isn't,
he isn't a,
the firebrand Ufo believer that some
people want them to be and he's not the
lunatic that other people want it to be.
But he didn't tell the
truth about his education.
Right.
Isn't that the case?
There's isn't.
There's some,
some finagling about,
yeah.
Well definitely like the
records of his education,
if they,
if he was telling the truth,
those records aren't around anymore.
Right?
Yeah.
So if he was telling the truth,
somebody expunged and yet,
and he's,
and he's basically,
his argument is,
well,
if I didn't have this education,
why was I hired to do this job?
Right.
You know,
I mean,
I was hired to do this
research by the government and,
and they have their records
of me doing the research.
So why did they let me do this research
for all these years if I didn't have the
education to do it?
But wouldn't there be someone
that went to school with him?
Like,
don't you,
you have friends from high school,
right?
Well,
not many.
I,
I do have some friends they can go,
yeah,
no,
yeah.
In fifth grade English.
And you bro.
And I got a couple of,
wasn't there a guy who went to
college with bibles are gonna say,
yeah,
he's in physics one o one.
Which he's out there.
Yeah.
I think there aren't people.
They remember him.
Okay,
cool.
So you,
you enjoyed the documentary.
Do you remember what the name of it is?
Uh,
what?
Oh God,
what is it called?
Bob Lewis are the guy who,
uh,
it's a new,
it's,
yeah,
somebody emailed me about that.
I'll say it.
And the guy who made it,
that's a real problem.
Like Ufo,
even this one is a fairly
rational documentary,
but it's,
uh,
but there's so bad.
Even this one,
it's just,
it's just got just bad filmmaking.
You know?
Bobby's our area 51 and flying saucers.
That's the,
the title 4.1.
That's it.
Uh,
Jeremy Cor.
Bill.
Yeah.
I think he's the gentleman.
And it's really accepted it all.
But it has like Mickey
Rourke doing voiceovers,
voiceovers at some point.
I love it as the wrestler,
a barfly so doing it as book
Koski that would be fine.
It's got 20% on rotten tomatoes,
but it's a movie with
your fucking you of Oh,
but I mean you've seen,
you've seen the,
um,
I know what I saw.
And out of the blue,
those documentaries,
you haven't seen it
because those are great.
Are they out of the blue is a great,
serious documentary
about the UFO phenomena.
And,
and I know what I saw is
one sort of tracing the,
uh,
the participants in the,
the disclosure hearings at
the Press Club in Washington.
God,
you're going to bring me back in.
And the Shit,
yeah,
I love the man.
I really wish they were real.
But I'm telling you my experience
talking to these people.
When I did that Scifi show,
I was like,
oh,
this is all nonsense.
Yeah.
But again,
that maybe those people were nonsense.
But the train military,
air traffic controllers,
the pilots,
yeah.
Government officials.
Like,
uh,
what's his name?
Fif.
Uh,
the governor of Arizona
is one of the guys in,
I know what I saw.
And out of the blue.
Oh yeah.
He was the king either
was told to like mock it,
brought it out,
guy dressed like alien.
These documents,
he talks about how much he
deeply regrets doing that.
And this is from out of the blue?
Yeah,
really interesting.
Deeply grip.
Maybe now it was not a governor anymore.
I was trying to get a
new angle and his career.
But he basically said,
you know what,
tens of thousands of people
saw these craft and we lied.
We came out,
we lied.
And he did he say who directed him to lie?
He didn't really,
he didn't say he was really directed dude.
He said he felt like people were in a
state of panic and he thought he could
relieve some of the fear
by making a joke of it.
And he said he really regret he really
just wanted to make relax people cause he
didn't,
he didn't know what else to do.
He said he didn't,
he said,
I saw it,
everyone else saw it.
And uh,
I didn't know how to calm people down.
So I made this joke and he
said he regrets it to this day.
There's another thing about these UFO
experiences and alien experiences where
people really dive into them.
Third seems to be the AC,
the atheists version of religion
to a lot of these folks.
Yeah,
yeah.
Which again,
I,
that I dismiss,
you know?
Yeah.
I don't think that's
likely to be the case.
That they're here to
save us or they're not.
No,
no,
no.
I mean that,
I mean,
the people that are believers
that are really into it,
it seems to be that instead
of focusing on a deity,
they're focusing on an alien civilization.
Transferring it to
daddy will save us.
Yeah.
That when we decide to point those nuclear
weapons at each other and you know,
it's going to come down and they'll
come down at the last minute,
talked to Russia and Trump and what's not
right.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's that,
but where were they
during her Shima Nagasaki.
Yeah.
Watching everybody deserves a lunch break,
but whoever,
whatever's going on that
it's not an intervention.
Well,
you know,
right after worth a right afterwards
was when a giant swarm of Ufo sightings
happened right after the
nuclear bombs were dropped.
Yeah.
That's when the,
there's a big uptick in Ufo
sightings and a lot of the,
yeah,
and as you said,
a lot of the incidents are
at nuclear missile sites.
They're getting going for
fuel or something like that.
Well,
they've,
uh,
I mean there's the one
in Arizona somewhere.
They,
they were Ufo showed up and shut
down the entire lunch system.
They,
all,
the missiles went
offline at the same time.
And it's,
you know,
and it's documented and it's
in the records of the time.
Don't dump all of the
missiles went offline.
You don't seem has never done this.
I,
I am literally right in the middle.
That's where I live on this
thing is I really don't know.
I'm not quite in the middle.
I'm in the,
I desperately want it to be real,
but um,
I'm still,
I'm calling bullshit.
Yeah.
I guess,
I guess I'm edging,
but my desire,
my desire is towards reality.
I want it to land as
came out as a big foot.
That bothered me.
He really,
yeah.
He came out as a big foot believer.
No,
he came out as the guy in the suit.
Oh yeah.
Remember that?
No,
that's just a lie.
What did you do then?
It about five or six from
Harry and the Hendersons.
That suit?
No,
this is him and his college friends.
They made there the big foot
and the in the famous video.
No,
that's Bob.
that's Bob Herana.
Miss land us.
No,
no,
no.
There's a video of Bob.
Bob Herana.
Miss was friends with the,
so that,
that story,
that big foot store is a real problem
because that's the Robert the Patterson
film.
Paterson was a con man who went
to jail for writing a bad check.
The paid for the very camera.
He used to film big foot.
He went out looking to film bigfoot.
Yeah.
They had a fucking suit.
I mean,
he was trying to get a suit.
They got a guy,
Bob Herano says a big tall
guy who walks like bigfoot.
Here's a video of yes,
the Patterson footage.
If there's a bit video that superimposes
Bob Herana Miss Walking on one side and
big foot on the other side walk the same.
Hey fucking this is,
it's the guy.
It's him.
And by the way,
big foot looks like a
guy in a big foot suit.
There's not a fucking
animal on the planet.
It looks like a person in an animal suit
and you never look at a swan and go,
hey,
that looks like a person who a swan suit.
Nope.
Things that like,
if you see a gorilla,
it does not look like a
person in a gorilla suit.
Totally out.
The anatomy is different.
That's the same with this
fucking stupid footage.
It's so dumb that the people
that buy in to them believe it.
It's like,
come on,
just look at it.
And it was always,
it was always,
see if you could find that footage.
Yeah.
Bob Herana Miss Ne Right next
to Bob Herana miss as big foot.
I mean there's a,
there's a video on youtube where they
show the stabilized image of this animal
moving across the,
and I,
by the way,
I've been to that area where they saw
that thing that's really interesting cause
it's in your show that yet.
But there's still like people like
anthropologists who will still say the,
you know,
that there's clear evidence that Kendall
and structure of this big foot fucking
sanctuary,
it doesn't match human.
If there's a single
thing that makes sense,
the vibe,
I mean it's there,
but it's not a single thing.
Yeah.
There has to be community.
The compelling,
interesting aspect of big foot is
that there was an animal called
gigantopithecus that existed as recently
as a hundred thousand years ago,
and they found teeth in the 1920s and
apothecary shop and China that we're an
unknown hominid.
And then they were like,
where'd you get these?
And then they found the area where they
found them and they started discovering
more.
And they've found some job,
bone fragments and some various bones.
He see this,
look at this,
look at that guy.
Oh my God.
I mean get the funk out.
Amazing.
That's the guy that's amazing.
That's him.
And he admits it.
Yes.
Same.
He admits it and got to talk to him.
It's fucking him talked about it.
He said,
told the story.
They said,
all right,
ready.
Go start walking on shape.
Exactly.
So put that guy in a big old
stupid fucking furry suit
and you have big foot and
that's great.
It's 100% him.
Um,
so does that mean there's
not one out there?
No.
So Jai can't apathic this was a real
animal that they think was a bipedal
hominid that lived somewhere around a
hundred thousand years ago for sure.
But most likely coincide lived
alongside human beings for eons.
Right.
And this thing was an eight
to 10 foot tall and North Sea.
She,
if you get an image of,
um,
the photo of a recreation of a Chai
can't tow pikas next to a modern human
being.
It's really interesting.
It was huge.
A huge buy fossil record of it.
It's a real thing.
Yeah.
I mean it makes sense.
Like if a gorilla,
we would,
it was a girl was like 500 pounds.
I mean,
the gorillas are considered
mythical creatures until like 18,
19.
Oh,
scroll up,
Jamie.
There's a better image right above you,
or was it even the 1900 says grills were
first just like officially discovered
does.
So there's a better one
where that shows up with the,
the fake bigfoot wrapped around his
keeps crawling.
There's,
uh,
that,
that's a good one.
Yeah,
there is,
that's the guy.
That's the guy.
So that's what that thing looked like.
So if you saw that in the woods,
you'd be like,
holy fuck and shit.
Hell yeah.
Eight foot tall,
gigantic hairy ape creature.
I wouldn't touch it like
that guys touching on.
He's a plant.
That's his buddy.
It's like when you see dudes
from Russia with bears and shit,
but,
so that's a real animal.
So that's probably why there's so many
mythological stories about this thing.
And the native Americans have more than
a hundred different names for these
creatures along the various tribes
signed that they thought was extinct for
around,
yeah.
Yeah.
Armored plated fish,
right?
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of animals that mean
that's cryptozoology in a nutshell.
There's a lot of animals that we think
are extinct that probably aren't,
but that one is very unlikely one,
cause it's,
you know,
it needed an enormous supply of food.
Yeah.
I mean it's a huge,
huge animal.
Yeah.
But the thing about it is
that the sightings occur all
in the Pacific northwest,
which if you follow the Bering land mass,
that's where they would have come across.
If they came across with humans,
they would've come across into Alaska
where there's a lot of sightings and down
into the Pacific northwest where
there's a lot of sightings.
Yeah.
But there's sightings
all over the country now.
But is there any fossil record
outside of Africa specific?
I get up.
I think it's new.
No,
no,
there's not.
No,
Yeah.
It's all,
it's a Asia actually.
Asia is where they find them.
Yeah.
It's not even Africa.
Ironically.
Yes.
Asians are tiny.
Oh,
right.
Tiny piece.
Well,
it's not a person,
not this one.
It's,
um,
it's,
it's compelling in the sense that
there was a bunch of different kinds of
hominids that existed.
You know,
the,
we now know that we
interbred with neanderthals.
Yeah.
That's,
most of us have Mandy total DNA in us.
Yup.
Well,
most white folks,
um,
which is interesting,
right?
Because it was,
it was the opposite.
If it was a black people had it,
it would be a really
controversial subject,
you know?
But instead it's dumb.
White people like me,
I have 57% more in the end are
tall DNA than the average person.
You know what?
I'm not gonna argue that neither.
I was like,
I knew,
I knew something was off.
Pretty sure my Indiana till count is low.
You'd be surprised.
The clubby carrier,
I got rid of that problem.
But that's a European thing.
A lot of Europeans,
you know,
in a breadwinner and he
has to tell us by the way,
that a way longer run than we have a,
well,
they call it Nice Europe.
Wait,
yeah,
wait before they were around for
hundred thousand years on change.
I mean homosapiens have only been around
all 300,000 shares and our ego says,
oh,
he usurped and we,
we,
we drove them into extinction.
And in fact,
no,
we just made them into extinction.
Just dilute it up.
Yeah.
We were ruined.
Their purity.
Right.
We probably drugged them a neutered them.
Yeah.
Probably once we figured
out how to do that.
Ah,
which is early.
Do you know about that?
A hobbit person thing that they found?
The island of Flores.
That's another one that they didn't
know until that it's free fee.
[inaudible] I think just the name of it.
It's a tiny little person like thing.
There was like three feet
tall and had large feet.
What are you guys looking at?
Me Not Bro.
No,
I'm just saying we all
have our own genetic,
his style.
That was a real thing that recently
an image and that that existed.
Yeah.
Homo florensiensis that's it.
Um,
and they existed as recently
as 14,000 years ago.
Found.
Yeah.
They coexist.
They coexisted with modern humans.
You and they think modern humans might
have wiped them out because they were
probably,
they think there's some
cannibal at not cannibalism,
but they preyed upon our
children and stuff like that.
They hate us.
They were eating us well.
There was one of those,
one of the things that I've read,
the speculation was
that they might have a,
there might've been an issue with
them like invading and trying to see,
you know,
like chimps have stolen
babies and eating them.
You know,
it's a really common thing.
Actually.
Babies are delicious.
Well that's why people like lamb,
unfortunately.
Yeah,
well exactly.
Well that was,
I heard it was a company that that
produced a Vegan version of human flesh.
I just trying to sell to people in
Papua New Guinea that's disgusting.
No longer allowed to eat human flesh.
That's hilarious.
I read this thing about people in New
Guinea that were cannibals and they were
talking to them after World War II and
they were trying to figure out how the
Europeans,
once they found out how many people
were killed during World War II,
they were trying to figure out how the
Europeans man to eat that much meat.
Yeah.
And then they told them no,
they don't eat the people they killed.
And they were horrified.
They were like in waste,
you waste all that.
All the people that kill in battle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That,
yeah,
it would be hard.
Yeah.
Well that's it.
That's a waste.
When it was a way to look at it and then
they believe they absorbed the noble
qualities of their enemy,
only the good spots by
eating certain spots.
You donate.
Yeah.
Have some if,
if,
if you're,
if you killed someone,
a battle who you thought was truly,
uh,
a great warrior,
that's what brings you back
to the whole Ufo thing.
That makes it so compelling to me.
So we have really serious protocols
for dealing with uncontacted tribes.
We don't engage with uncontacted tribes.
And we find,
I mean we almost universally at green,
I mean when the loggers do
in the Amazon assholes and mean people,
but the,
the,
the idea in the scientific communities,
we should leave these people alone.
And so when they find
these uncontacted tribes,
whether it's North Sentinel Island,
where that missionary was
killed recently or the Amazon,
when they're going through these
jungles and finding these small bands of
people,
they overwhelmingly,
everybody wants to back off and leave
him alone and they are so close to us.
I mean they are human beings.
They are Homo Sapiens,
they have tools,
they have civilization,
they have law,
they have all these different things
that live in these communities.
They're us.
Yeah.
And we back off,
imagine what aliens.
Imagine what aliens would do.
I'm interested in an engine.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's their consciousness,
Jamie.
Cause they don't want it screws
up the human flesh alternative.
That healthy human flesh alternative.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's a hoax from like all fortunate one
who from Burger I'd be tobacco food,
Burger Fried.
Who?
Food Burger.
Once you see Tofu processed,
you let it go.
Oh this is,
this is,
is this really good for you?
Like what?
This is so processed man.
So fucking slots,
like reduced to nothing
that's and then formed again.
Can I just eat soybeans?
Like what the fuck is this?
What you can do is you
can buy a bag of frozen.
That's the way to go.
Don't fucking Tofu rose
tasting toothpaste tube.
Well it tastes like nothing.
Yeah,
it's like it's weird.
So weird choice.
Yeah.
I can't,
yeah,
I can't stand anything made from Tofu.
But I think that if
aliens did see us there,
they would probably take a hands off
approach if we weren't totally ruining
everything.
Like if we didn't have
some anti matter weapons,
some black hole weapon that we're just
going to just fucking nuke on New Mexico
just to see how it works happen.
And if they saw,
if they saw that it was going to burn
a hole through the planet and kill
everything on,
they might step in for a second before
they launched cern glider and open up a
black hole that it will create a particle
that would devour the fabric of the
university.
Yeah.
It was a black hole that would expand
and expand and expand and db did what we
did.
God,
man,
maybe we restarted.
Yeah.
Maybe we were in a parallel universe.
Maybe we were knocked off our
timeline into another place.
It makes less sense.
Yeah,
it was.
It was the thing that was going
around in the unit a little while.
The evidence of multiple universities
that we pop in and out of different
capacities.
Right.
Like the fact that we,
it's a multiverse,
the Ford logo,
let's say.
Do you remember you recognize this
part of the Ford logo and they see,
most people never noticed it.
It's a weird little squiggle in the AF.
Really?
Yeah.
The Fedex thing blows people's minds to,
what's that?
The Arrow one arrow.
Exactly.
Bring ups Fedex.
If you'll never not see the Arrow again.
Yeah.
Same thing with the Ford logo.
It's like there's
perceptions.
It's like,
hmm.
And sit there the whole time.
And I did.
I didn't know there was an arrow there.
People will insist that
the Fedex Arrow is really,
oh,
interesting.
Okay.
But that's an accidental error.
No,
you think they designed it in there?
Where's there?
They definitely designed it right there.
Yeah,
right there.
The white part.
Now not,
you'll never see it again
or never not see it again.
Know.
It's funny,
Huh?
But I mean that could be
like four years before it.
Yeah.
Was the four eagle little
squiggle in the f Jews.
Why is that a squiggle?
Why is it that's ridiculous?
It actually makes an effort like that.
It actually spells fjord
or forward toward fool.
Is that an eye?
What is it?
Why would they squeak a lot?
Did they do that?
Oh,
it's not,
they didn't use to do that in return.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
The people who insist
that it died in jail.
In jail.
So was there always a squiggle?
When did,
what is that?
Is that a real forward,
that little thing?
When did they make the squiggle?
Okay.
That's normal because that's what I
thought the Ford thing looked like until I
saw this maybe in a future
that they stopped the squiggle.
At some point they must
have more the opposite.
Maybe they add the squiggle,
bring up the squiggle without some on.
Or did you do the research?
What's a modern forward
go to a 2019 Ford Mustang.
Let's see that.
Let's see if they'd have the squiggles.
A squiggle.
Now it does.
I think maybe some the squiggle asshole
wanted to justify his existence by
ruining their beautiful logo.
Yeah.
Um,
well good.
Let's see.
I mean the logos do chain that
does the squiggle squiggle.
Yeah.
That's a new Mustang.
So the squiggle is a current,
Yup.
The squiggles current.
It really doesn't fit.
No,
it looks stupid.
It would look better
without that stupid scores.
The only thing that's saving,
that's it.
Squiggles it.
No one noticed it up until now.
Now I'm never an academic notice.
The Mandela effect,
I hate Mandela effect,
but that just seems like
people fucking with something.
That's not broken.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Um,
it's like,
let's just remember when they showed up,
reg.
Remember when they came
up with a new coke?
Fuck God was up like a riot riot on their
head and sort of a parallel universe.
It's just a stupid idea.
He just ruined coke.
Coke's made with real cocaine.
The original coke.
Yeah.
No,
today.
Today.
Yes.
I thought they,
they replaced it with caffeine.
No,
they use cocoa leaves.
Smacking the thesis.
Coca leaves for flavor.
Yes.
In fact,
the company,
dude,
it's crazy.
The company that makes the coke,
the company that uses the coca leaves
that brings in the coca leaves to make
Coca Cola is the number one
creator of medical grade cocaine.
They use that coca leave to
also make medical grade cocaine.
There's no cocaine in Coca Cola,
but there is a flavor
that's a bunch of different four logos.
Yeah.
Over the years.
See,
I just drink.
I drink diet coke.
Would you 1927 to 2003.
Wow.
All of them,
Huh?
I like the one in 1903.
That's actually a pretty dope.
Um,
Google coke.
They use coca leaves to make Coca Cola.
They still do it.
Actually do.
And then the company does that
because it makes cocaine because the,
yeah cause the recipe for herbal.
There's like a lot of
herbs that go into coke.
Yes it's a flavor.
But the Diet coke is just chemicals.
It's all artificial.
I remember I was in school when the new
coke thing happened and then he'll get
this advertising besides producing
the cocoa flavor agent for Coca Cola.
The Stephan company extracts cocaine
from the coca leaves which sells it to
Mallon crock.
A Saint Louis Missouri pharmaceutical
manufacturer that is the only company in
the United States licensed to
purify cocaine from medical use.
But I'll use,
yeah,
there you go.
So they're actually
using actual coca leaves.
So someone,
I guarantee you if you
follow the paperwork,
there's a bunch of cocaine
hanging around guys,
additives,
residual.
Those guys,
they get a little bit here,
gives you a little pep me up.
Right.
That's what's amazing is that you're
not allowed to chew the leaves cause
apparently chewing the
leaves is really healthy.
You get flavonoids,
it's actually good for you.
And it gives you a pickup
that's very similar to caffeine.
Yeah.
I mean that's why people living in
those forests been chewing them.
What's this chain?
I just one of those weird things that
pops up when you see a 90% of their sales
are done,
the United States,
but it's an Irish tax
registered manufacturer.
Uh,
Irish economic explosion.
Weasel moves,
one of them.
Tax Weasel moves.
Yeah.
Taxes.
That's it bizarre when you find out this
giant corporations that make billions
of dollars,
if they're all in Ireland
and the weasel out of taxes,
you know?
Yeah.
How much did I say they
don't believe in socialism?
Did you read that at many
taxes I paid last year.
Amazon zero.
Zero.
Well,
you know,
it's nice that it exists and you know,
you get a one click and you
have some toilet paper said Tom,
I'm happy to use their product.
And that's why they need,
that's why they needed $1 billion in
tax breaks from the city of New York.
How does that work?
You could pay zero in taxes.
Zero.
Yeah.
And why did they need those
tax breaks in Long Island?
Maybe that's why I feel
like you fucking dummies.
You let Amazon fuck you over like that.
Or maybe that's why they're coming here.
All their money's in Ireland.
Ireland's doing great.
Yeah.
Islands kicking ass cocaine shit.
And I'm going to Ireland.
Yeah.
Aliens got a bank somewhere.
I'm going to curl.
And there's leaves occurrence.
There's some sort of a ballot initiative
where they're trying to put a silicide
been,
uh,
in the same medicinal category
as they're using marijuana.
Marijuana will be able to get
an in store in California.
They're trying to do that.
And past medical medical silicide
been for therapy while here.
I had been on antidepressants since news
radio days and I'm just actually just
went off it this month,
this month.
How are you feeling?
Good,
look.
Great.
Good.
Yeah,
I feel very good.
Part of it was because I had
this head injury a few years ago.
What happened?
I had a,
well,
I,
uh,
I don't know if you remember this.
I used to drink quite a bit.
I do remember.
Do you remember that?
Now I,
uh,
now I do one night,
about four years ago,
uh,
I went and got really drunk
or right before Christmas and,
uh,
wound up,
I guess at a bar called the must downtown,
right around the corner from my apartment.
And I fell down on the patio,
just fell over like that.
I would call it our,
I would call it a dead fall backwards
and landed back God and hit my head on
the,
on the stone patio with enough force that
my brain gave me a black eye from the
inside of my head.
It's called cerebral hemorrhage,
chipping away at night.
I had a subdural Hematoma.
I was in the ICU for four days.
Get this bread.
I had one of those black right.
Red Blood eyes.
Yeah,
I do somewhere I think one Instagram.
No,
I guess my of this that's happened.
Oh,
Jesus.
Sorry.
Thank you.
They can,
they can get it to sound
like Emory though this out.
Can you just like total recall?
You can just remove things,
but Chrissy know Chrissy
has the photos of all that.
Uh,
but,
but the weird thing was,
uh,
and then I decided I was all right,
what do I said?
All right.
I got to quit drinking.
And I thought,
you know,
it'd be hard,
but I'll do it.
And uh,
and I kept waiting for it to get
hard to not drink and it never did.
Like I'm not four years.
I haven't had a drink at four years.
Uh,
and uh,
heroin.
Yeah.
But don't do anything.
Nothing.
No Pot.
No,
no,
no.
I wish I could.
I don't like pot.
I wish I could enjoy it.
Don't you like about it?
And it makes me very quiet and paranoid.
That's my favorite part.
And I like about it.
But you seem very lucid
when you're on pot.
It seemed very and very communicative.
Yeah.
Whereas when I had smoked pot,
I can't put a sentence together.
Oh,
it must be friendly.
Yeah.
It makes me very withdrawn.
Alcohol makes me friendly.
So what that for me too.
Yeah.
We say the one thing I miss about
drinking is the liking people
like me more than,
yeah.
But I have,
because of this brain injury,
it never was hard to not drink.
I,
my urge to drink was gone from
getting knocked in the head.
Yeah.
Wow.
And also I noticed over
the couple of years is it,
I haven't had any depression.
Whoa.
And so,
uh,
just before,
I guess in like November,
I said,
I talked to my doctors,
I wanted to go off the
antidepressants and see what happens.
And uh,
so I've been like gradually weaned off
and just this month took like the last
day antidepressants for about a month ago.
So how long has the weaning process,
it's like about three months and node.
How do you really addictive?
Yes.
And how do you do it when you're weaning?
It's just gradually reducing the dosage,
the daily dosage,
and then doing it every
other day and then it's gone.
But they have a protocol.
Yeah.
And so did he discourage,
you know,
eye doctor was,
he was excited about it,
he said,
oh,
that's great.
Congratulations.
Good,
good.
You know,
and said,
but you know,
keep keeping touch and
like Israel doctor too,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
He had to think he had
a reflector on his head.
That's all you need,
a lab coat.
And he was like,
you know,
and he's like,
I think he lives in the neighborhood.
He's always walking around outside.
That's him.
That's a doctor.
So we did it.
And uh,
and so now I'm about a month,
about a month in without
any antidepressants.
What is the difference?
Uh,
I don't really know yet.
I mean it's hard.
I don't feel different age.
It,
uh,
I def,
I definitely feel more emotional.
Uh,
you know,
I kept crying at the Oscars.
Really?
Why,
what arts?
All of it.
Why you could've had Kevin Hart host.
Yeah,
definitely more.
I think I'm more emotional.
Yeah.
And uh,
you know,
we'll see what happens.
Hopefully.
I mean,
hopefully I'm part of it.
I was thinking,
I hope it will help with writing cause
I felt like I was having trouble coming
up with story ideas.
You do hug me too long now.
Yeah.
Oh,
I'll always become a predator.
That's what it is.
But I feel good about it.
The important thing.
So the only thing is emotions
and you feel more creative,
you feel more in touch.
You don't know yet.
I don't know.
And I don't even know if I feel,
I just know,
I definitely know that there's a,
there's a heightened emotionalism.
Has it affected your him
provides us a little while at,
doesn't seem to happen.
I was worried it would,
I was worried that I would be like,
I might not be able to go out and
do those shows cause that'd be more,
I was worried it might be
more moody and you know,
Yeah.
But it's so far it hasn't affected them.
Um,
cause I went on them and news radio
cause I couldn't work at one point.
I got to the point,
right.
It's couldn't work anymore.
And that's when I started going on
anti depressants and it saved me,
you know,
so totally believe that people should get,
get on meds and stay on them.
You know,
it's,
it definitely helps some people.
I mean it saved a couple
of my friends for sure.
Yeah.
There were suicidal and just
really didn't know where to turn.
They got on the right ones
and they had experiment.
I don't think I would've
made it through the,
you know,
the 2000.
Wow.
You know,
like we just lost Brody Stevens just died.
Yeah.
He got off his meds.
He,
um,
he,
he didn't like the way it felt
to be on them and you know,
so he's so hard.
That's such a hard one to take
because everyone loved that guy.
And to think that everyone,
I mean,
he has no haters.
I don't know.
A single person was like,
that guy was a dick.
No,
no,
no one.
Everyone loved him.
And it hit everybody really hard
from close friends to people.
Just knew him a little bit.
Like I knew him just a little bit.
He was so sweet,
but he was so,
so tortured.
He was just in pain all the time.
And yeah,
it's just,
it's so strange that you think the
thing that people like most is for other
people to love them and care about them.
And everybody loves Brody.
Yeah.
But yet he couldn't,
it just couldn't go on.
But I never,
I've never known Brodie
to have a relationship.
I've never known him to have
a special someone in his life.
And I mean that,
that alone probably be very,
very depressed.
Well especially if,
if everyone loves you but you don't
feel connected to any of them.
Right?
Like how empty that rails and
that's the core of depression name.
Yeah.
But it's also the core of depression
I had having had depression.
One of the things that hits you is that
feeling that you just can't connect and
does it,
was yours coming about when your
first marriage was breaking up?
I mean I had lifelong depression but I
didn't get it treated until that point
when it was like,
you know,
it was like,
uh,
yeah cause of the marriage was breaking
up and I had to fly to Africa twice in a
month to see my kids.
And you remember the time that like
a protected a reporter from you?
I'll let the TCA,
yeah,
he was on malaria medication and drinking,
which apparently enough,
so super sweet kind Dave was,
was going to kick someone's ass and I
literally had to like hold on to him and
kind of want to see that I wasn't,
I hadn't because that was,
yeah,
the thing,
I've been flown to Africa
twice and it just got back.
We did the tcs and I think
I also threw a glass at,
uh Oh fuck.
I'm blanking on his Tony,
Tony,
uh,
Jesus.
Fuck them blankets and nice guy.
Sorry Dude.
We're handled.
Tony.
Jesus.
I left.
Tony's a great guy,
but I was like out of my skull and I just,
yeah,
well that was,
that was her partner.
I took his report.
You took his tape recorder and Duncan
and his drafts and threatened to kick his
ass.
Yeah,
cause I was,
yeah,
I was drunk and yeah,
I was like,
oh my God,
have to do something.
Sorry,
I missed,
I was like,
I have to stop this.
Oh,
this is crazy.
I can just,
yeah.
Well then it was after that that,
that I just went on antidepressants
because I crashed really hard after that.
And it was like one the things about that.
I said you could go to work,
you can't do anything.
You were experiencing that combination
apparently of the malaria medication and
alcohol is like a crazy combination.
And then you got to that jet lag and the
trauma of being separated from my kids.
The malaria pills on their own.
Yeah.
I looked at her,
I left Harare,
uh,
to the sound of my,
My,
my eldest child screaming,
daddy don't go.
Even now I can't talk about,
Ooh God.
See,
it's not worth having kids.
No,
no,
it isn't.
Yeah,
I have one.
I have a 17 year old.
Yes.
It's good.
They're on their own now.
In the year you can just write them off.
Yeah,
that's right.
Next year he's going to call it.
But anyway,
if you are out there,
yeah.
Get on meds and stay on them.
Yeah.
Like Brody should have stayed on his meds.
Well,
you know,
I just,
I wish we could have all known and how
he was and how close he was to that.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing.
It's like,
people think like,
uh,
like suicide things that
if you're close to suicide,
it's the most rational choice
you'll ever make when you're,
when you're that close.
Right.
It just seems like the most sensible
way to the issue this because it's
otherwise it's too much pain.
Yeah.
I heard someone describe it as,
um,
it's not even on a
commercial decision burning.
It's jumping out of a burning building.
It's like there's that choice
into the burning building or,
yeah.
What's that feeling right where you go,
this is not an emotional decision.
I mean,
there's no choice.
I've had two friends hang
themselves this year.
Yeah.
Wow.
I mean that,
that is,
I never thought I would ever say that.
Yeah.
I never thought that that would be a way
that people would be going out either.
Yeah.
I remember when we had Drake say there.
Oh,
he was hard.
Yeah.
That was a hard one.
I knew Drake back in the,
uh,
but essentially my open mic days.
Yeah.
He was a,
an established comedian in Boston
and I was just starting out.
Oh yeah.
But so even though I'm
happy that my brain injury,
yeah.
Seems to have cured my depression.
That's fucking crazy.
Do you know the brain injury was
responsible for Sam Kinison the car crash?
Right?
Yeah.
We got hit by a car when he was
a kid and became this wild man.
Yeah.
Same thing with Roseanne.
I mean one of the reasons why I wanted
to have Roseanne on the podcast and talk
about her,
her issue with,
uh,
her television show and everything and
her outbursts and all the crazy stuff she
says on Twitter.
Yeah.
It's,
cause I know her and I know her past.
And so I right away at the
beginning of the podcast,
I was like,
let's get into what
happened to you and it,
cause I don't think she
talked about it that much.
She was hit by a car.
She was in a fucking Sikich is
psychiatric corps for nine months.
Yeah.
Like she was gone and she was never
the same person to get on with this.
She was 15 years old.
She was walking across the street and
someone had glare and their eyes from the
sun and didn't see her hit her with a car.
The fucking,
the hood ornament went into her head.
I mean,
she had a severe brain injury.
She couldn't count anymore.
She couldn't do math anymore.
She was,
she was a very smart student before
then and then crippled by it afterwards.
Yeah.
And then for nine months she was in
a psych ward and she talked about it.
I'm like,
I wanted people to know like this is,
anybody knows that they know now,
hopefully more than they knew then.
But people that work with her did,
so when they were writing her off,
I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
this is like taking a person
with a broken leg and saying,
you know,
I'm mad at you that you can't run.
Yeah.
And this is the thing.
And like whatever your,
I mean,
obviously Roseanne said
some crazy and terrible and,
and messed up a lot of people's lives,
but she's also a genius.
She's a comedic genius.
She also made that show one of the best
shows on TV when it was originally on
the,
she's always done crazy shit.
You remember once you grabbed her crotch
and spit when she did the national
anthem and everybody hated her,
then they went crazy.
And this is like early two
thousands she did that.
She was always wild.
But that was why she
was so good as a calm.
That was her appeal.
She did not give a fuck.
I'm predictable.
Just wild.
And that is like Kinison and
it came out of head injuries,
you know,
really well.
There was the famous story of the guy
who was I guess working in a mine.
There was an explosion and uh,
like rebar went through his brain and
they said before that he was the nicest
guy and after that he became,
they said he became evil.
He was just an evil person.
After this rebar went
through the brain and a,
I mean there's also happens and whether
the Texas school book depository shooter
and were not,
it wasn't school book depository,
Texas Tower,
the Texas Tower shooter to Texas
Tower shooter had a brain tumor.
They found that out after he died.
Like,
Whoa,
this is what it was.
But you also have people who have
suffered brain injuries and come out of it
being able to speak French.
Yes.
Or play piano.
I know oral spray paint it.
They probably have a brain injury,
but yeah,
I'll be able to like suddenly can
paint photo realistic paintings.
Yeah.
Yes.
I never had any artistic ability before,
but they have a brain
injury and it unlocks it.
All I got was sobriety
at to call shake sample.
It's amazing though.
It does happen for real.
Well they don't.
Yeah,
they can learn it quicker I think.
I don't think they know it
and don't come out knowing it.
Well,
the piano I've heard peanut field like
literally could sit down and knew what to
do.
Well,
there's certain things that happened,
right.
If people have certain spectrum issues,
Where there are far better at mathematics,
far worse at social interactions,
there's,
there's pathways that are more lubed for
you to figure things out that aren't as
confused by social issues
or social stigmas or just
normal human communication.
And I think there's people in history,
a lot of them are,
a lot of them,
a lot of super fucking
geniuses are on spectrum.
Einstein didn't speak till he was five.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Like they thought he was,
they thought he was,
he was mentally retarded.
Wow.
Yeah.
That was back when they
should use that word.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Now you can get in trouble.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Um,
when you had the head injury,
so how much time was it
before you felt like,
did you just stop drinking on the spot?
Yeah,
I think it was December 22nd I remember
Jackie was wanting to visit you and you
remember it was Hawaii,
right?
They were going up.
No,
New York.
Yeah.
I was going to go to
Christina Molina to New York.
We're going to go near for the,
for the holidays.
For Christmas and new years.
My wife was like,
no,
you're not because you did this,
you don't get to go to New York with your,
with your family.
And they went,
they went that way.
But you know,
but then again,
Chrissy,
I woke up in the ICU
and Christina Molina were there and
we celebrated Christmas in the Icu.
Wow.
You know,
and that was a pivotal moment.
Yeah.
So you just decided on the spot.
No more drinking.
Yeah.
And just said,
all right,
I think I'm done.
And,
and,
and again,
I was preparing cause I,
but a few years earlier,
like it's about maybe eight years earlier,
I tried quitting drinking.
You told me about this,
you were talking to me about pot.
Yeah.
We were talking about you really are.
I've got to stop drinking.
How far did you get a,
I went to a year and a
half without drinking.
I think that's pretty good.
Yeah.
I hate it.
Hated it.
Hated every minute of it.
Really?
Yeah,
it was like every,
every day.
I thought it would be
nice to drink every day.
He just hung in there
for a few hundred days.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
but like this time,
yeah.
But even now,
like I'll still let go.
Oh yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I do miss the taste of Scotch,
you know,
because you've worked so hard to
learn to like it and you know,
you really like Scott.
What are the positive
benefits of not drinking,
of not drinking?
Um,
you don't hit me.
That's true.
But that's the only positive for you,
Paul.
That's true.
I thought we were really affect me.
Whatever.
Uh,
I think the,
uh,
not that,
that I don't do anything to,
uh,
unknowingly embarrass my daughter
if I need to embarrass my daughter.
Now it's deliberate,
you know?
Uh,
that,
yeah,
this mostly just,
just,
you know,
remembering things,
knowing where I was the night before.
Now I don't drink and I embarrassed my
son every single day by walking around.
Yes.
Just and just,
just being next to them.
Yeah.
It's like,
come on dad.
Do you think you are a genetic
alcoholic or is this like a learn thing?
Well,
it's hard to say cause I mean
obviously alcoholism runs in my family,
but is that just because you know,
we were raised by a horrible alcoholic.
Do you think it's genetically genetic?
It's probably genetic
predisposition to it.
Yeah.
I think there's genetic
connections to almost all behavior.
Yeah.
Yup.
I don't think,
you know,
I don't think there's a,
there's a lot of real freewill.
Right?
I've come to that more
and more as I get older.
I mean I battle with it.
Cause obviously there are conscious
choices that you can make and yeah,
especially when you really make an effort
to move into a certain path of the way
of the thinking and believing.
But what's causing that,
you know,
how much of his life experience
you can make conscious efforts to,
I guess ameliorate the
influences of your genes.
But it's like,
it's like you could,
you could live healthy,
eat healthy and avoid risks and you're
still going to probably die around 110 at
best.
At best if everything goes great,
unless some new advanced medicine,
we're going farther that guys come on.
We very well could we very well could.
I mean,
I had David Sinclair from Harvard on,
uh,
two weeks ago who's a life extension
specialist who fascinating shit.
We've got to stop those
telex and I'm snapping
off.
I remember the,
the,
the notion because people
will always talk about it.
You know,
human lifespan is we used
to live to be 40 on air,
but human lifespan hasn't
changed at all since,
since essentially,
uh,
the beginnings of,
of human beings hasn't changed at all.
The,
the oldest possible lifespan is
still exactly the same as it was,
you know,
uh,
50,000 years,
you know,
and has just,
it's just more people,
fewer people are dying young frack,
right?
More people are living
close to their potential.
And a lot of that is infant mortality.
If you look at the actual statistics,
the reason why it's so low,
it's not necessarily that
no one lived to be 65 back.
Babies died thousands of years ago.
People did live to be over a hundred,
but back then,
scratch your foot and
then died two weeks later.
You know what I mean?
Yes.
Yeah.
But maximum human lifespan
hasn't changed at all.
And that's the thing that maybe
is going to start changing.
Do you exercise at all?
Never.
Never,
ever in your life.
Uh,
I mean,
as a kid I liked sports.
Never like go for a hike or anything.
Very rarely.
Very refill.
Really good.
I probably would,
yeah.
It would relieve a lot of tension.
Just,
just a little height,
you know,
you don't have to do anything crazy.
Yeah.
No,
I keep meaning,
especially now that I'm,
I think not just getting older,
but actually old.
Yes.
I'm actually old dude.
We were young when we met.
I know old people.
I know.
If a kid sees us like,
oh this is old dudes in their 50s yeah.
We're old dudes.
Yeah,
I know.
It's crazy.
I'm,
yeah,
I'm weird.
I'm really almost 60 56
that's almost 60 it is,
you know,
it's closing in line.
Yeah.
And a terrible looking 39.
It's true.
Which is good though.
That gives you longevity in this business.
Yeah.
That's my staff director.
That's why Steve Martin looks good cause
he never looked Young's hair from the
jump.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
you could just listen to
like books on tape and walk.
It's great man.
You know,
just find a place of
like go Runyon Canyon.
Just go walk it.
It's so nice cause you can do it
at your own pace and it's so good.
Elevates your heart rate without anything
crazy enough to go out and have to do
anything.
Nuts started.
You'll amaze 11 on the road.
So I hadn't been doing it on the road,
but I haven't like started doing like
some like lightweight lifting and that
sort of thing.
Great.
Yeah.
Do you know what?
Just hire someone feels good to come
over your house and tell you to do it.
I think that's the way to do it.
Have someone else make you do it?
They're there.
10:00 AM you?
Oh Hi.
Bob are way out of it.
Yeah.
Get some hot Russian lady yells at you.
That sounds great.
Great.
Now there's my next divorce.
Are you still doing standup?
I know you're doing stand up.
You know what I am going to do?
I have to come up and again,
no.
Okay,
go ahead.
All right.
Last one.
But no,
I stopped stopped once I got doctor Ken.
Oh,
okay.
Stop,
you know,
stop doing stand up once
you got the television.
Yeah,
yeah.
I love that guy.
I don't see him enough.
It's,
it's cool to see you two guys together.
It is,
you know,
cause that's,
I don't want to say it's a lifetime ago,
last a lifetime,
but those are in your,
in 20s and 30s.
I mean,
I was a totally different
human being when I was 27.
You were 100%.
What's,
yeah,
I guess it was crazy.
I was,
I was completely insane.
What,
what,
what was the switch for you?
Well,
I've got older and wiser and
realize how fucking stupid it was.
But also,
uh,
I was only a few years
removed from fighting.
You know,
when I first started doing a news radio,
it was only like five years removed from
my last fight and I still was sparring.
So it's still getting
hit in the head a lot.
Would you like come in to work
with a face full of bruises?
No,
not that bad.
I started doing Jujitsu somewhere around
news radio to run 96 so that was like,
I stopped really s kickboxing
very much after that.
And then I think I stopped entirely
when I was like 30 I just realized like,
this is got to stop.
I gotta stop doing this.
So you weren't smart,
you like this fit guy that just left it
all behind or where you were always did
you always keep it up?
I work out for sanity.
I've always worked out for hand
and a lot of people that do that,
I need it,
you know,
for whatever it is.
And also like my personality was sort
of forged by having these moments of
clarity after extreme exertion.
You know,
there was those sort of,
my personnel was formed that way.
Like if I had a problem,
if I had something that
I was dealing with,
I would just blow it out at the gym and
then I'd have a better look at it and
probably wind up calling
somebody in apologizing or so.
Interesting.
It's like a rush of oxygen to the brain.
Yeah.
Well,
Russell Rush of oxygen,
the brain and maybe even more important,
more important that a
draining of excess energy.
Right?
Because I think,
uh,
once you,
if you develop a certain way,
like I did martial arts literally most
of my adult life and growing life up
until that point.
And so my,
my body had sort of developed with this
need for that exertion in order to have
clarity.
And so I just am like this is my formula.
I'm sticking with it so I never let it go.
It's amazing that you did stick that
you've never gone away from that.
I can't,
I won't think right.
I don't think right.
I think we,
I think so much better when I exercise.
I mean there's no comparison.
It's like a pill.
I did this a sober
October fitness challenge,
things with my friends uh,
in October and uh,
we went crazy.
We were working on like three hours a
day cause we were wearing these heart
monitors.
And one of the things that I wrecked
cause we were trying to like get a certain
score and whoever got
the highest score one,
one of the things that I recognize from
that was that the more I did in terms of
cardio,
especially the,
the last things bothered me,
the middle or more clarity I had,
the more peaceful I felt,
the more at ease.
I felt no more,
no one internal chatter.
You know,
I just think,
um,
for whatever
reason,
I mean everyone has their
own biological makeup.
And for me,
my boss,
my biological makeup is entirely dependent
on the health benefits from it as if
it's a giant.
But for me,
my mind actually choose.
Yeah.
You know,
a friend of mine said that
sitting is the new smoking.
Yeah.
I think we say that,
that does that.
Does that make it good for you?
It's a compression of your,
your disks for sure.
Especially your lower back.
And if you don't have good posture,
it's not good,
but you can mitigate it with exercise.
You know,
just,
you gotta make sure
that you don't only sit,
you know,
stretch yourself out
and take a yoga class.
I should be writing this down.
Seriously.
[inaudible] Oh,
do you do any exercising?
I'm starting more.
I found out if it's hilarious,
I would like to have kind of a
had a golf back injury type thing.
Coughs.
Like we swing that fucker.
This is a lot.
It's hard.
It's hard on your back.
So I go,
I go to the doctor and uh,
x rays me and I got freaking
scoliosis that I never knew.
Oh Wow.
All my life.
Oh,
one at the bottom of my spine
when I can do about that.
Laugh at me.
By the way,
I'm in there with my wife Jackie,
while while he brings in the x,
x rays,
puts them up on the thing and goes,
hey buddy,
you got scoliosis?
And she bursts out laughing.
Now everybody says that's
why you walk that way.
Oh my God.
For Real.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Every school at some point had when the
one hot girl was scoliosis who had the
headgear.
Every school,
she didn't have the headgear
on and she's really hot.
They had to have headgear scoliosis.
They tried to straighten it
out and back then it had metal,
like metal rods
head.
Yeah,
I thought that was a broken neck.
Scoliosis.
That's a neck.
Hey,
I got a girl that had a whole chest thing,
big plastic that she had to wear
to keep it like spine street.
She didn't wear it for like
two years or something.
Didn't work.
I sure.
I guess I don't,
I mean shit,
he didn't stay in touch.
What do they do with it?
Uh,
I still the same thing and I had a
meeting with the specialist and he's like,
well I like operating on people.
I like,
that's what I do.
That's why I got into this.
I'm like cutting them when they're asleep,
but you know,
you could do some exercises and some uh,
you know,
physical therapy and
stuff to alleviate it.
And if it gets so bad down the road,
I could maybe help you out with some rods.
So there you went in there because
there was an initial issue I had,
I had like issues when I was young.
When I used to do like
track and field and stuff,
I would get like a pain in an area and
then it Kinda went away most of my life.
Then I started golfing and then they
go off more and more and then one day I
didn't warm up.
I did a,
I did a twist and it just freaking,
yeah,
and it was in a certain spot
and I went and it was like,
you've always had this condition,
but dose is a picture of Paul.
There you go.
I know.
I look terrible in that.
That's a strange look.
Wow,
that's hilarious.
That's like what's going on with his Dick.
That's like an like getting constricted.
It's like,
and that's,
that's something they'd
wear on in the group pants.
Maybe like just the costume from TLC.
We were born.
Yeah,
it is androgynous phase.
Yeah.
They said,
I just got to suck it up and exercise
and get a strong core and I should be
fine.
Take Yoga as I got to do that.
I love it.
That's,
I keep hearing for old
people all the time.
Did you just start it as an old person?
No,
I didn't do when I was younger and then
I didn't do it seriously until about
three,
four years ago.
Then it's do it and now we do it
because you always did martial arts and
obviously like yoga was for people that
just were too lazy for martial arts.
No yogas.
Yoga does some things that really enhance
martial arts in because the hot yoga
guy.
Yeah,
I like that stuff.
That seems like torture to me.
It is a little bit of torture,
but it's really good for you because your
body produces heat shock proteins that
are similar to when you go into a sauna.
It feel great when you come out
of there and you feel great,
but it's also really
good for inflammation.
Just the act of doing it in cell itself,
in the extreme heat like sauna would
be amazing for you to for that reason.
Yeah,
when heat shocked,
but there's a woman named Doctor Rhonda
Patrick That's a regular on the show.
I have her on all the
time and she's genius.
She's a huge believer in sauna and they
did a study and what was it like Sweden
or some shit where they took people
with a regular sauna use versus not.
And the regular sauna use had a 40%
decrease in all cause mortality.
Heart attack,
stroke,
cancer.
Yes.
Because you're,
when you're regular using it 20
minutes a day for four days a week,
what they're essentially saying is that
your body producing those heat shock
proteins and those sidechains
20 minutes of Yoga.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Heat,
heat,
sauna.
Just sitting in a sauna going on out here,
sit in the Sauna,
20 minutes that just doing that is a fee
because almost all ailments and issues
and deal with inflammation.
Right.
Yeah.
Well I,
that's,
I,
I have to pinch nerves right now
and like herniated discs and uh,
and they were like,
I was like,
like on the couch for like two months.
Couldn't sell it from your injury?
Uh,
no I don't.
I don't think it was,
I don't know what it was from,
but it was a,
it may have been,
but it was,
uh,
like one day it just started my arm,
my arm started hurting and pin
pointing towards your neck.
Yeah.
It's like somewhere in here,
the herniated disc.
That makes sense.
Is your lower right?
Yeah.
That's your lower back.
But the uh,
yeah,
I like from my arm,
her two months,
my arm,
my arm felt like it was going to explode.
It felt like there was this
pressure building up in it
and it was literally like
Blake,
he was going to explode
and I was getting like a,
what do they call,
uh,
the kind of the shots you get when
you're having an epidural.
I was getting epidural shots
that were doing nothing.
I was taking 16 Advil a day.
Jesus,
take that.
And I was getting no pain relief.
And then I started using CBD.
Ah,
and like that,
it was gone.
Amazing.
And even now it's like,
you know,
I couldn't,
I couldn't do anything
for two solid months.
I couldn't get off the couch.
CVD is incredible.
Yeah,
I use that stuff so much
that I got the rubbing stuff.
That's great too.
It makes it better for about two days.
My friend Hahn's though,
he told me he has a shortage,
recent shoulder surgery and he said
everybody likes to use the rub stuff,
but you really should take it
with the edible stuff like oil,
oral CBD and rub stuff works together.
Smoking.
I started,
I had the cream.
No,
just pop a pill.
I seem seen green that I've rubbed and
then I started using the tincture with
it.
We have some here.
If you want some case in the back that
that case is given to us by a stay.
He'd we'd,
yeah,
the big chest chest of marijuana.
That's a lot of,
it's crazy and here's the thing.
Turn lights on and off tincture
along with the the cream.
Yes.
Perfect.
My arthritis went away too.
Yeah.
I had like this finger stuff meant,
yeah,
I could,
I couldn't bend my hand
and it's like that's gone.
Automation.
Yeah.
The knee.
My arthritis in my knees completely gone.
It'll go away even further
if we cut out sugar.
Yeah,
that sugar and bread.
I did that and I felt fantastic.
That's the sugar was gone crazy.
Right.
Pours in ourselves our whole lives.
That's a,
that is a poison sugar.
Yeah,
absolutely.
That's the one thing when I quit drinking,
I wanted more sugar.
Oh,
he has one effect because I,
I've never had a sweet tooth really,
but one the,
when I quit drinking,
I suddenly was craving that chocolate.
Of course it makes sense.
I should go back to zero sugar.
I went zero sugar for a
while and it felt amazing.
I'm just like a little
tiny bits here and there.
Do you do zero?
I do.
I had dessert Saturday night and had a
big old cake with ice cream on it after
dinner.
So no checker when a date with the wife
at Mastro's we have this big fat steak
and then I got this butter cake with
it sounds like ice cream and oh,
it was delicious.
That was great.
So good.
That sounds amazing.
I say no to that.
And occasionally you got to say fuck it,
but I just,
for the most part,
I'm on like an 80 20 diet.
80% of it is super healthy.
And then the 20% is
occasionally I'm on Goff.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I've seen that.
That,
uh,
two,
two and five fasting
two days a week.
You do like 600 calories
the rest of the week.
You can do whatever you want.
I'm on the seven and zero seven pig out.
I do,
um,
uh,
intermittent fasting.
So every night if I,
you know,
have dinner at 7:00 PM,
I don't eat anything for 16 hours.
I didn't want to hear at Passover.
Yeah.
Sorry.
That was me.
I found like my cholesterol just
dropped through the floor and then,
yeah,
when I,
when I did that.
But I haven't been doing it lately.
Yeah.
No Boys,
we just did three hours.
Oh my God.
Can we do this more often?
That's really our only our second podcast.
Believe it or not.
It's crazy.
Yet I'm in much better shape this time.
Yeah.
Great man.
Everything's wonderful.
Um,
tell people the name of your podcast,
Ian read says,
don't say with Paul and Dave.
Yes.
But once you get there,
be warned.
Don't say cut the following day,
but we can't put that in print.
Um,
give away your Instagram handle.
Name,
Twitter,
all Greenberg one that's Erg.
And I'm just a fully on Instagram.
And I'm David David,
Dave s Foley on,
on Twitter.
And our show is,
uh,
don't say with Palten Palten,
Dave,
and you know,
and,
and if I've gotten this wrong,
and Dave,
you can just do,
you can just do a web search on your own
and maybe not have everything spoon fed
to you.
Yes.
You Shit together.
Fuck work for once.
Yeah.
All right.
Beautiful.
Thank you guys.
It was fun.
Thanks for having us.
That was great.
Thank you.
That was really fun.
Yeah.